Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 21. Mailbag? So, this is a pretty exciting episode. Mailbag episode. One quick thing before we get started, if this is your first time, if this is your first
由 Host Tornado 提供托管服务。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 21 期。邮件袋环节？这是一个非常令人兴奋的一期。邮件袋特辑。在开始之前先说一件事，如果这是你第一次，如果这是你第一次
episode that you've listened to, listen to a different episode. So basically, this is, you know, we've accumulated a lot of questions throughout the other episodes. And so this is our chance to sort of answer a lot of those questions and sort of engage in a dialogue about that. But, you know, this is deviating highly from the original format of the show. And so if you kind of want to get an essence of, if you want to learn a programming language or get essence of the show, watch the one four. Okay. With that said, well, maybe actually the guests will be funnier than us. So then it'll make this episode better than the other episodes. Oh, that's true. If you didn't like the last episode, watch
听的节目，请去听听别的。基本上，我们已经在之前的节目中积累了很多问题。所以这是我们回答这些问题并进行对话的机会。但是，这与节目的原始形式有很大偏差。所以如果你想了解节目的精髓，或者想学习编程语言，请看第一期到第四期。好吧。话虽如此，也许嘉宾会比我们更有趣。那样的话，这一期会比其他期更好。哦，那倒是真的。如果你不喜欢上一期，那就看
this one. Okay. And if anybody who ends up on this episode is better than us, we're going to kick you off and make you start your own podcast. Yeah, totally. So, anyways. Yeah, so basically... Take it away with the news. Or a personal... We always start with a personal story. So, you know,
这一期吧。好吧，如果最后出现在这一期里的任何人比我们强，我们就把你踢出去，让你自己去开播客。是的，完全同意。总之。是的，基本上……从新闻开始吧。或者是个人的……我们总是从个人故事开始。所以，你知道，
they're having the hurricane scene. Actually, they had the hurricane. And, you know, as having the hurricane hurricane scene actually they had the hurricane and uh you know as floridians we've been through plenty of hurricanes ourselves and one thing that i always wondered was um why don't they set up like why don't they have a mode in your cell phone where you can do like some kind of ad hoc so for example let's say the cell phone towers go down right um wouldn't there be a cell phone mesh yeah like a cell phone peer-to-peer network where you could call people and as long as one person in the network had access to the tower um then they would you know you'd be able to get your call through
他们遇到了飓风。实际上，他们确实遇到了飓风。而且，你知道，作为佛罗里达人，我们自己也经历过很多飓风，我一直想知道的一件事是，为什么他们不设置，为什么不在手机里设置一种模式，让你能进行某种自组网？例如，假设手机信号塔倒了，对吧，难道不能有一个手机网状网络吗？是的，就像一个手机点对点网络，你可以给别人打电话，只要网络里有一个人能连接到信号塔，那么你就能打通电话。
and so it turns out they have something like this but um for like policy reasons it's not completely implemented. So in some phones, like in some circumstances, you can actually call 911 and it will route you through other phones, which is pretty incredible. And it's something that's not on by default. But like so just a heads up for real, the technology behind broadcasting and correct me if I'm wrong. You probably know more about hardware stuff. But so any cell phone can also broadcast. like if you can receive you can also broadcast something to do with like the physics behind it well it's a two-way communication yeah but so i mean like the tower can talk to you and you could talk to the tower but you can also talk like broadcast
结果发现他们确实有类似的东西，但出于政策原因，它没有完全实现。所以在某些手机上，在某些情况下，你实际上可以拨打 911，它会通过其他手机进行路由，这真是太不可思议了。而且这不是默认开启的。但只是提醒一下，广播背后的技术，如果我说错了请纠正我。你可能对硬件更了解。但任何手机也都可以广播。如果你能接收，你也能广播，这与物理原理有关。嗯，这是双向通信。是的，我的意思是，信号塔可以和你通话，你也可以和信号塔通话，但你也可以向外广播。
outwards well i mean if you're talking to tower you are broadcasting oh really you don't know where the cone or something i mean i don't so yeah that technology exists but i mean i think in general you just have a sphere around you of you know gradient just you know going down by the cube law or whatever power farther away you get oh i didn't know that okay so that makes sense then so yeah you can totally do it from like a physics math but i think the reason it's not implemented overall is a couple reasons. One, if you ever study sensor networks or whatever, you know certain nodes happen to become gateway nodes
嗯，我的意思是如果你在和信号塔通话，你就是在广播。哦，真的吗？你不知道锥形区域之类的东西吗？我的意思是，我不知道。所以，是的，那种技术是存在的，但我的意思是，我认为通常你周围有一个球体，你知道，功率会随着距离的增加而按立方定律或其他规律衰减。哦，我不知道这一点。好吧，那这就说得通了。所以，是的，从物理数学上讲，你完全可以做到，但我认为它没有被全面实现的原因有几个。第一，如果你研究过传感器网络之类的，你知道某些节点会成为网关节点
or key nodes that a lot of stuff flows through. And if you become that guy, your phone's going to drain. You're just going to have your phone in your pocket, not using it, and go back to it and be like, why is it all gone? Oh, that's so true. So you have to have all this extra stuff to make it not be that the second thing also is that when the cell tower is broadcasting to you it's got for all intents and
或关键节点，大量数据流经它们。如果你成了那个人，你的手机电量就会耗尽。你只是把手机放在口袋里，没用它，回头一看，心想，为什么电全没了？哦，那太真实了。所以你必须有所有这些额外的功能，才能避免这种情况。第二点是，当信号塔向你广播时，它拥有所有意图和
purposes infinite power right it just sits there and beams out really strong as whatever limits they have set but your cell phone has very limited so it hears quietly but then it also talks quietly but the cell tower has very expensive antennas and equipment to be able to you know receive that quiet message and pick it up from the noise so i think that's the whole mechanism versus if you're talking to other phones it's not going to have the same range as you did the tower gotcha because the receiving antenna on the other phone isn't as strong so it would probably work and in some instances probably would be better especially in densely populated areas like maybe like New York City or something. But in most regions,
目的上的无限电力，对吧？它就坐在那里，以他们设定的任何限制发出非常强的信号，但你的手机非常有限，所以它听得很轻，说话也很轻，但信号塔有非常昂贵的天线和设备，能够接收到那种微弱的信息并从噪音中提取出来。所以我认为这就是整个机制，而如果你在和其他手机通话，它就不会有像信号塔那样的范围。明白了，因为另一部手机上的接收天线没那么强，所以它可能在某些情况下有效，特别是在人口稠密的地区，比如纽约市之类的。但在大多数地区，
like I don't think you're going to, I wouldn't know what the range is, but it's probably not that far. Oh, that makes sense. That makes sense. That's my top of the brain response. But it would be cool for emergencies like you have a special mode, you put it in. So I think the way it works is the carrier can put your phone into this mode. And so then you can... Only if they can talk to your phone. Oh, yeah.
我不认为你会，我不知道范围是多少，但可能没那么远。哦，那说得通。那说得通。这是我的第一反应。但在紧急情况下，如果你有一个特殊的模式，你把它打开，那会很酷。所以我认为它的工作方式是运营商可以把你的手机调成这种模式。所以你就可以……只有当他们能连接到你的手机时。哦，是的。
So how does that work? Oh, so I guess you have to get put into this mode, like, before a disaster or something. I'm not really sure. It's interesting, though. I guess it works for hurricanes and not for earthquakes. They anticipate the disaster coming. Yeah. For earthquakes, it might not work.
那它是怎么工作的？哦，所以我猜你必须在灾难发生前被调入这种模式。我不太确定。不过这很有趣。我猜它对飓风有效，对地震无效。他们预料到了灾难的到来。是的。对于地震，它可能不起作用。
One of our listeners was pointing out Batman. Yes, this did happen in Batman. Did it really? It's totally awesome. They subverted the phone network to detect where everybody was. Isn't that one of the movies? Did you see the... Oh, we should say spoiler alert.
我们的一位听众提到了蝙蝠侠。是的，这确实发生在蝙蝠侠里。真的吗？太棒了。他们颠覆了电话网络来探测每个人的位置。那不是其中一部电影吗？你看了吗……哦，我们应该说剧透警告。
Sorry. Oh, yeah. Well, there you go. That's a really old Batman. Oh, it's the original? Oh, then it's totally cool. Yeah, not the new one. So do you see the Die Hard?
抱歉。哦，是的。好吧，就是这样。那是很老的蝙蝠侠了。哦，是原版吗？哦，那太酷了。是的，不是新的那部。那你看了《虎胆龙威》吗？
What is it? This is the last Die Hard. It's like the Die Hard and Never Stop Dying or whatever. I don't know. It's some cheesy name. But in the last one, they were going around trying to catch this hacker. And the terminology was like palm forehead the whole movie. They've gone into our interwebs and they're stealing all
是什么？这是最后一部《虎胆龙威》。就像《虎胆龙威：择日而亡》之类的。我不知道。名字很俗气。但在最后一部里，他们到处抓这个黑客。术语简直让人无语。他们进入了我们的互联网，正在窃取所有的
the webs. There won't be any webs left and it's just like, come on. Okay, actually we're getting a correction. I don't like this. People are correcting us while we're talking. Normally I like to pretend that we're always right. Yeah, every other episode we're always right. It's actually a mesh protocol
网，不会剩下任何网了，这简直是，拜托。好吧，实际上我们收到了更正。我不喜欢这样。人们在我们说话时纠正我们。通常我喜欢假装我们总是对的。是的，其他每一期我们都是对的。实际上是一个网状协议
network. Ah, okay. So I listen to the Twit. You ever listen to Twit? This guy Leo Laporte or whatever, he has a pretty popular general tech broadcast. And he always has people in his IRC chat room, and sometimes they have conversations back and forth in the chat room or whatever. And then, yeah, I understand now why he sometimes gets detracted. Yeah, totally.
网络。啊，好吧。所以我听 Twit。你听过 Twit 吗？这个叫 Leo Laporte 的人，他有一个非常受欢迎的通用科技广播。他总是让人们在他的 IRC 聊天室里，有时他们在聊天室里来回对话之类的。然后，是的，我现在明白为什么他有时会分心了。是的，完全同意。
But it's good. It's good. Live feedback. Yeah, this is pretty awesome. So the other thing that we should talk about is the election. In case people didn't know, there's actually an election going on in the U.S., which some of you might not know or might not care about. But join us.
但这很好。这很好。实时反馈。是的，这太棒了。所以我们应该谈论的另一件事是选举。如果人们不知道，美国实际上正在进行选举，你们中的一些人可能不知道或不在乎。但加入我们吧。
No, I'm just kidding. Wait, I'm not saying that. I'm totally kidding. But, no, it's super interesting. And the thing that's interesting to me is how every election, the technology changes, you know, drastically because the entire four years has gone by. And I feel this also with the Olympics. So, you know, as we talked about on that show, you know, we went from, you know, the Olympics only being on TV to then you had TiVo and you could record the Olympics on TiVo. That was cool.
不，我开玩笑的。等等，我不是那个意思。我完全是在开玩笑。但是，不，这超级有趣。让我觉得有趣的是，每次选举，技术都会发生巨大的变化，因为整整四年过去了。我觉得奥运会也是这样。所以，正如我们在那期节目中谈到的，我们从奥运会只能在电视上看，到后来有了 TiVo，你可以在 TiVo 上录制奥运会。那很酷。
And then it was starting to get on the internet like nbc had this deal with microsoft where they had like some of the olympic events there and then now with youtube this time broadcasting the entire olympics in certain countries yeah in certain countries yeah there's still policy problems but from a tech standpoint it's cool to see every four years like a massive leap like not just some quanta of leap like a gigantic leap i was watching katie couric street uh on a rebroadcast on abc being rebroadcast live on youtube talking about the number of twitter follow twitter users this year versus last election yeah and how that has ballooned you know a lot and i would say even twitter's what is the cliche,
然后它开始出现在互联网上，比如 NBC 和微软有这个协议，他们在那上面放了一些奥运赛事，然后现在有了 YouTube，这次在某些国家转播了整个奥运会。是的，在某些国家，是的，仍然存在政策问题，但从技术角度来看，每四年看到一次巨大的飞跃，不仅仅是某种量子的飞跃，而是巨大的飞跃，这很酷。我当时在看 ABC 的重播，在 YouTube 上直播，谈论今年与上次选举相比的 Twitter 用户数量，以及它增长了多少。我会说甚至 Twitter 的，那个陈词滥调是什么，
jump the shark, right? Even me, I already see people don't use Twitter the same way they used to to have conversations, except on those TV shows and people are like, hey, Katie Couric, talk about me. Yeah, exactly. Hey, mom. And they have terrible filtering on that, by the way.
跳鲨鱼，对吧？即使是我，我也已经看到人们不再像以前那样使用 Twitter 进行对话了，除了在那些电视节目上，人们会说，嘿，Katie Couric，谈谈我吧。是的，完全正确。嘿，妈妈。顺便说一句，他们的过滤功能很糟糕。
I saw one where it was like, it was literally like this guy was talking and the Twitter feed was scrolling by and this one guy was like i think aliens are like retarded and it's like had nothing to do he's talking about hockey and i was like what spammer yeah it's like you just detected like oh like this is a upcoming hashtag like start putting it in my messages i don't know yeah maybe how did they don't have like a person you would i i'm sure the like high level ones do yeah like presidential debate or whatever they probably did for that so but um they were talking about social media and i think
我看到一个，简直就是这个人在说话，Twitter 信息流在滚动，有一个人说我觉得外星人是弱智，这和他谈论的曲棍球毫无关系，我就想，什么垃圾邮件发送者。是的，就像你刚刚检测到，哦，这是一个即将到来的标签，开始把它放进我的消息里，我不知道。是的，也许他们怎么没有一个专人，我肯定高级别的会有，比如总统辩论之类的，他们可能确实有。所以，但是，他们谈论了社交媒体，我认为
that is a good point like people hash this out and it's interesting to see when people post politically which some people like and some people don't like political posts on social network but it's interesting to see the engagement from not only like we said people in the united states but people in other countries yeah it's really interesting actually people are fascinated by our process here. It's not straightforward. It's very confusing. Oh, it's so confusing.
这是一个很好的观点，人们对此进行了讨论，看到人们发布政治内容很有趣，有些人喜欢，有些人不喜欢在社交网络上发布政治内容，但看到不仅是我们所说的美国人，还有其他国家的人的参与，这很有趣。是的，实际上人们对我们的流程很着迷。这并不简单。这非常令人困惑。哦，太令人困惑了。
I mean, I tried to explain the electoral college. I had to explain that at lunch today. It's so hard. It was a nightmare. And it's like, I don't even, like, I mean, I understood it, the process, but I don't understand. People started asking questions like, why is it like this? Oh, I mean, the why is, it's fairly, I mean, it's straightforward to say why.
我的意思是，我试着解释选举人团制度。我今天午餐时不得不解释它。太难了。那是一场噩梦。而且就像，我甚至，我的意思是，我理解它，这个过程，但我理解不了。人们开始问为什么是这样？哦，我的意思是，为什么，这相当，我的意思是，说出原因很简单。
Like, you know, it's an alternative, but some people say it shouldn't be that way anymore. Somebody said why, so for example, if like like, let's say California has, I don't know. People are going to be bored about politics. They're going to be like, I thought we were over with the election, now we're listening to programming, throw it out, don't talk about politics. Okay, but we'll do one, one real quick.
就像，你知道，这是一种替代方案，但有些人说不应该再这样了。有人问为什么，所以例如，如果，假设加利福尼亚有，我不知道。人们会厌倦政治的。他们会说，我以为选举已经结束了，现在我们在听编程，别谈政治了。好吧，但我们会快速做一个。
Like, if California has like 50 electoral votes, I don't know how many it has, but let's say 50. If half the people voted one way and half voted the other, like shouldn't 25 go? Like the winner take all. I had a hard time like explaining like why that makes sense. So I guess in theory like it used to be that way sometimes. Like people could decide. And I think in some states it's still, it's like Maine is still that way partly.
就像，如果加利福尼亚有 50 张选举人票，我不知道它有多少，但假设是 50 张。如果一半人投一边，一半人投另一边，难道不应该分 25 张吗？就像赢家通吃。我很难解释为什么这有意义。所以我猜理论上它有时是那样的。人们可以决定。而且我认为在某些州仍然是这样，比如缅因州部分地区仍然是那样。
But the, or in some states it's district by district. So it's not like you say, but it's like, so you have, so electoral college is the two senators plus however many representatives you have. And so the representatives are geographically located by a certain region and they can cast votes by whatever the popular vote in their region is. And so that's even a more highly divided way of doing it. But I think that the, I mean, the whole reason why it's winner-take-all,
但是，或者在某些州是按选区划分的。所以不是你说的那样，而是，所以你有，所以选举人团是两名参议员加上你有多少名众议员。所以众议员是按地理位置划分的，他们可以根据他们所在地区的普选结果投票。所以这是一种更高度分裂的做法。但我认为，我的意思是，为什么它是赢家通吃的整个原因，
the whole reason that Electoral College is kind of there, aside from some legacy reasons also, is to provide that you have a state like Alaska or North Dakota or something that are very sparsely populated, very few people, but they still have a lot of cares. It still matters a lot to them. So if you give them only a percentage vote like you get in the popular vote they essentially get no say and who gets elected a president even though they're a part of the united states arguably like other people are because there's a lot of land
选举人团存在的整个原因，除了某些历史原因外，是为了确保像阿拉斯加或北达科他州这样人口非常稀少、人很少的州，他们仍然有很多关注点。这对他们来说仍然很重要。所以如果你只给他们像普选那样的百分比投票，他们基本上在谁当选总统的问题上就没有发言权，即使他们是美国的一部分，可以说和其他人一样，因为那里有很多土地
resources there they might produce a lot like there's all these different measures of how important various states are and so this is kind of trying to be a compromise between every person is one person and like people are proportional to the importance of their state. Gotcha, gotcha. I'm probably butchering that, but that's okay. It sounded good. I should have used that argument at lunch. It would have made a lot.
资源，他们可能生产很多，所以有所有这些衡量各个州重要性的不同标准，所以这试图在每个人都是一个人和人们与他们州的重要性成比例之间达成妥协。明白了，明白了。我可能说得一团糟，但没关系。听起来不错。我午餐时应该用那个论点。那会很有用。
Instead, I was just like, I don't know. So on to the news. Yep. You got the first news article. Okay. So I think this is pretty awesome. So I run Linux at home. I have a Windows machine that I use just to play games and mainly because my games are on Steam. And I heard you can run Steam through wine, but it's like, it's like,
相反，我只是说，我不知道。所以进入新闻。是的。你有第一篇新闻文章。好吧。所以我认为这太棒了。我在家里运行 Linux。我有一台 Windows 机器，我只用它来玩游戏，主要是因为我的游戏都在 Steam 上。我听说你可以通过 Wine 运行 Steam，但它就像，它就像，
I mean, you can whine about running Steam under wine. Yeah, exactly. Bad punss i'm sorry so so you can you can do this but it's like i had a windows machine from when i was in college and it's kind of like why not just just keep it for this right rather than deal with it but um steam is coming to linux very shortly and so this article is actually a press release from nvidia um in the press release, they talk about how Steam is going to be like, they're already testing Steam on Linux with their cards and things like that. So you can sort of insinuate from this article that it's eminent, the Steam.
我的意思是，你可以抱怨在 Wine 下运行 Steam。是的，完全正确。糟糕的双关语，抱歉。所以你可以这样做，但就像我大学时就有一台 Windows 机器，这就像为什么不留着它做这个，而不是处理它。但是，Steam 很快就要来到 Linux 了，所以这篇文章实际上是 Nvidia 的新闻稿，在新闻稿中，他们谈到了 Steam 将如何，他们已经在用他们的显卡测试 Linux 上的 Steam 之类的东西。所以你可以从这篇文章中推断出，Steam 即将到来。
I also heard that it was faster. Really? Like, I saw something. They were saying it runs better. Yeah, because I have issues with Steam. Now, granted, my computer is rather old because it's an old Windows box, but sometimes if an app or if a game on Steam decides it wants to update, instead of updating in the background, it'll just lock my Steam.
我还听说它更快。真的吗？就像，我看到了什么。他们说它运行得更好。是的，因为我在 Steam 上有问题。当然，我的电脑相当旧，因为它是一台旧的 Windows 盒子，但有时如果 Steam 上的应用程序或游戏决定要更新，它不会在后台更新，而是会直接锁定我的 Steam。
I can't do anything with it. Yeah. Maybe they fix the lock. No, it'll be great. I mean, it would be nice. A big hindrance to using Linux for everything is this, right? A lot of the applications and stuff just don't work very well or aren't supported at all.
我什么都做不了。是的。也许他们修复了锁定。不，那会很棒。我的意思是，那会很好。使用 Linux 做所有事情的一个大障碍就是这个，对吧？很多应用程序之类的东西运行得不是很好，或者根本不支持。
And so as that becomes less of an issue. So I think things like also the Humble Indie Bundle, which we've talked about several times. And their big thing is it has to be cross-platform to be there. I believe that's one of their things. It has to be on every platform to be featured in one of the bundles. I think that's really good, having
所以随着这个问题变得不那么严重。所以我认为像 Humble Indie Bundle 这样的东西，我们已经讨论过好几次了。他们的大事是它必须是跨平台的才能在那里。我相信这是他们的要求之一。它必须在每个平台上才能出现在其中一个捆绑包中。我认为这真的很好，让
developers address this. Also, as a buyer, if I buy that, then I'm less locked into what... It's not just DRM. Steam has some DRM issues. Now that they're going cross-platform, maybe some of that will be a little bit better. There's the DRM locked in, but even non-DRM, you can still
开发者解决这个问题。此外，作为买家，如果我买了那个，那么我就不会被锁定在什么……这不仅仅是 DRM。Steam 有一些 DRM 问题。现在他们要跨平台了，也许其中一些会好一点。有 DRM 锁定，但即使是非 DRM，你仍然
be locked in because of what the only system that supports the games or applications you have. But as more are available across platform, then I'm less locked in, and I can move back and forth how I want. DAN GALPIN- Yeah, imagine when Windows 98 came out, it supported USB. And Windows 95 didn't. That was one of the big changes.
可能因为只有系统支持你拥有的游戏或应用程序而被锁定。但随着越来越多的跨平台可用，那么我就不会被锁定，我可以随心所欲地来回切换。DAN GALPIN- 是的，想象一下 Windows 98 出来的时候，它支持 USB。而 Windows 95 没有。那是最大的变化之一。
And so, you know, if something like that happens again, and if all your games are on Steam, and now Windows 8 comes out, and Windows 8 supports some hardware that you need that, you know, you can't upgrade, you know, so if you end up in this position where, like,
所以，你知道，如果再次发生这样的事情，如果你的所有游戏都在 Steam 上，现在 Windows 8 出来了，而 Windows 8 支持你需要的一些硬件，你知道，你无法升级，你知道，所以如果你处于这种位置，比如，
you have to upgrade your computer, you don't want to be forced to upgrade into Windows. if you have the opportunity to upgrade into linux and keep all your existing apps like that's going to be very enticing you know yeah i mean this is a whole like shift in the way we purchase things so it went from scarcity right like i buy bread then i take that you know those atoms and molecules home to my house right like this is the scarcity thing and not to get into economics of it um because don't know anything about it but uh but it's just like now we have less and less of that like we buy things which are digital which okay i mean that's pretty straightforward but then things like netflix like i pay every month but i don't really
你必须升级你的电脑，你不想被迫升级到 Windows。如果你有机会升级到 Linux 并保留你现有的所有应用程序，那将非常有吸引力，你知道。是的，我的意思是，这完全是我们购买东西方式的转变，所以它从稀缺性开始，对吧？比如我买面包，然后我把那些原子和分子带回家，对吧？这就像稀缺性，而且不要进入经济学，因为我对它一无所知，但它就像现在我们越来越少那样了，我们购买的东西是数字化的，好吧，我的意思是这很直接，但像 Netflix 这样的东西，我每个月都付钱，但我并没有真正
own anything if i stop paying i lose no matter how much money i've spent total like i lose all of that the day i stop paying paying And or the next month But yeah, so I mean I lose that but then you have these kind of hybrid things Like a steamer there's been video services where you purchase download things But they still have this DRM or this connection back to where if that company goes away You can no longer authorize your stuff to play you may or may not be able to get it kind of, you know, unlocked so you can keep playing. So you've bought a game,
拥有任何东西，如果我停止支付，无论我总共花了多少钱，我都会失去所有这些，在我停止支付的那一天，或者下个月。但是，是的，所以我的意思是，我失去了那个，但你还有这些混合的东西，比如 Steam，或者有视频服务，你购买下载东西，但它们仍然有这种 DRM 或这种连接，如果那家公司倒闭了，你就不能再授权你的东西来播放，你可能或者可能无法解锁它，这样你就可以继续玩。所以你买了一个游戏，
but the game is not exactly yours to do what you want with. And even we talked about previously about the new consoles going to also try to do this kind of thing about linking or locking your game to your specific console. So it's not, if that one dies and you go buy a new one or you upgrade to the version 2 like you may or may not be able to take it depending on the good graces of the console developer and the game developer yeah so from like uh like security cryptography you
但游戏并不完全属于你，不能随心所欲。甚至我们之前谈到过新主机也将尝试做这种事情，关于将你的游戏链接或锁定到你的特定主机。所以如果那个坏了，你去买一个新的，或者你升级到第 2 版，你可能或者可能无法带走它，这取决于主机开发者和游戏开发者的恩惠。是的，所以从安全密码学，你
know point of view if if you're not hitting the internet so so if any security measure is just on your machine then you should be able to crack it. Like from a math standpoint. Yeah, theoretically, eventually, with enough effort, you could crack it. Yeah, and I mean, these passwords and things are cracked all the time. But as soon as you make it to where you have to transfer some information to and from the cloud, then you can end up in a situation where you can't crack the password, at least not easily. And so, yeah, that's...
知道，观点来看，如果你没有连接互联网，所以如果任何安全措施只是在你的机器上，那么你应该能够破解它。从数学角度来看。是的，理论上，最终，只要有足够的努力，你就能破解它。是的，我的意思是，这些密码之类的东西一直被破解。但一旦你让它必须在云端传输信息，那么你就会陷入一种无法破解密码的情况，至少不容易。所以，是的，那是……
There's a lot of problems. And I feel like it's one of those things like and maybe it's just but you have like the 99.999 percent separate from the like one percent but yeah we just have like all the people out there and there's oblivious to this they're just giving the monies to the companies and they don't understand the implications long term right yeah there's the classic thing like the the mother who bought for their kid like all this music on their ipod and then wanted to buy their kid a zune and like oh wait nothing works on here like well i don't under like why not yeah it's just confusing and like in some ways it's like well what are you gonna do like i mean that's you know caveat
有很多问题。我觉得这就像其中一件事，也许只是，但你有 99.999% 的人与那 1% 的人分开，但是的，我们只是有所有那些人，他们对此一无所知，他们只是把钱给公司，他们不了解长期的影响，对吧？是的，有经典的例子，比如给孩子买 iPod 上所有音乐的母亲，然后想给孩子买一个 Zune，然后说，哦，等等，这里什么都不能用，好吧，我不明白为什么不。是的，这只是令人困惑，在某些方面，就像，你要做什么，我的意思是，你知道，买者自负，对吧？但另一方面，就像你感觉，我不知道，就像我们没有很多，我喜欢当事情带来选择时。是的，所以我认为像 Humble Indie Bundle 这样的东西，也就是无 DRM，或者甚至 Steam，现在他们正在提供其他东西。我仍然对那个不是 100% 舒服。但如果他们给我带来价值，对吧？所以他们为不再支持的游戏提供了激励，使其重新得到支持，这样它们就可以因为这种分发机制而在 Steam 上以低价值转售。好吧，我的意思是，那里有价值。你知道，如果一个游戏在 Steam 上和不在 Steam 上的价格一样，我宁愿
emptor right buyer beware right but it on the other hand it's like you feel i don't know like we're not having a lot of like i like when things bring choice yeah so i think things like the humble indie bundle which is you know no drm or, or even Steam, now they're making available other things. I still am not 100% comfortable with that. But if they're bringing me value, right? So they provide an incentive for games which were no longer supported to become re-supported so they can be resold at a low value on Steam because of the distribution mechanism like that. Okay, I mean, there's a value there you know i may still want if it's if a game is the same price on steam and not on steam i'd rather
买不在 Steam 上的，但现在这甚至越来越难了，因为我买不在 Steam 上的，哦，没有 DRM，那么，好吧，好吧，那就是主意，对吧？但你确实这样做了，因为现在所有这些东西都有一些其他奇怪的东西，你必须用这个东西注册之类的。而且就像，哦，好吧，如果我必须为这个做那个，我不如直接在 Steam 上拥有它，它会处理所有这些。是的，我前几天买了飞行模拟器，微软飞行模拟器，新的那个。我想它叫 Flights。它就像，重命名了。好吧。
buy it not on steam but now that's even harder and harder because i buy it not on steam oh without the drm then well right well well that's the idea right like but you do because now all these things that are like also have some other weird thing that you've got to register with this thing or whatever. And it's like, oh, well, if I'm going to have to go ahead and do that for this, I might as well just have it on Steam where it kind of handles all that. Yeah, I got the flight simulator the other day, the Microsoft flight simulator, the new one. I think it's called Flights. It's, like, rebranded. Okay.
而且，是的，它不在 Steam 上，但它仍然要求我在云端的某个地方有一个 Windows Live 帐户和各种 DRM。好吧，关于那个谈得够多了。所以我看了微软 Surface，既然我们在谈论操作系统。你真的看了吗？是的。那它怎么样？是的，告诉我们。
And, yeah, it wasn't on Steam, but it still required that I have this, like, Windows Live account in the cloud somewhere and all sorts of DRM. Okay, well, enough talking about that. So I checked out the Microsoft Surface, since we're talking about OSes. Did you really? Yes. So what's it like? Yeah, tell us.
所以我当时在商场，我就想，我要去看看。所以有几件事要注意。首先，外面有些人可能会翻白眼。那是我见过最繁忙的微软商店。是的，而且不是吗……这么多人。所以在当地的商场……我不知道是不是同一个。
So I was at the mall, and I was like, I'm going to go. So a couple of things to note. First of all, some people out there might roll their eyes. That was the busiest I'd ever seen the Microsoft Store. Yeah, and isn't it so... So many people. So at the mall locally... I don't know if it's the same one.
它看起来和苹果商店一模一样。好吧，而且不是吗……这么多人。所以在当地的商场……我不知道是不是同一个。它看起来和苹果商店一模一样。好吧，是的，我的意思是，是的。但它是在旧金山地区，湾区的这个特定商场。它就在对面，字面意思就在对面，
It looks exactly like the Apple Store. Well, and isn't it so... So many people. So at the mall locally... I don't know if it's the same one. It looks exactly like the Apple Store. Well, yeah, I mean, yes. But it's at this specific mall that I went to here in the San Francisco area, the Bay Area. It is right across, literally right across the street from,
或者从苹果商店的商场过道。这太疯狂了。就像你可以字面意思看到一个的前窗，看到另一个。而且，好吧，我们有一些。哦，继续。我会整理好的。
or the mall aisle from the Apple Store. And it's crazy. It's like you can just like literally see out the front windows of one and into the other. And, okay, we're having some. Oh, go ahead. I'll sort it out.
好吧。总之，你可以从一个看到另一个。所以你通常站在微软商店里，周围人很少。有几个人，有人在前面玩 Connect，Just Dance 游戏。哦，是的，是的。你看看对面的苹果商店，你看到，就像，人！到处都是人！所以，但微软商店确实有，
Okay. Anyway, so you can see from one to the other. So you normally stand in the Microsoft Store and there's like very few people around. There's a couple of people, somebody playing Connect, the Just Dance game in the front. Oh, yeah, yeah. And you look across the Apple Store and and you see, like, people! Everywhere, people! So, but the Microsoft store does have,
进去还不错，你知道，而且很合理。当我看着 Surface 时，就像有一排人，就像每个 Surface，他们摆出了很多 Surface，就像很多平板电脑。我们可能让人们困惑了。摆出了很多平板电脑，
it's pretty nice, like, going in there, you know, and it's reasonable. And when I was looking at the Surface, there was, like, a line, like, every Surface, they had so many Surfaces set out, like, so many of the tablets. We might have confused people. So many of the tablets set out,
而且，就像，每一个，都有一个或两个人的队伍，等待在用它的人用完后尝试它，所以我们四处走走，我发现了像另一个区域，就像，哦，好吧，这就像尝试键盘，但我真的不在乎，我只是想看那个东西，所以它运行的是 Windows 8 还是……所以它运行的是 Windows 8 RT，这是 Windows 8 的 ARM 版本，所以你不能只是带上你自己的应用程序，你的旧 Windows 95 应用程序，然后运行它们。当你使用它时，
and, like, every one, there was, like, a line of one or two people to, like, wait to try it after the person who was using it was done so we kind of walked around and i found like this other area that like oh okay like this was like to try out the keyboards but i don't really care like i just wanted to see the the thing so is it running windows 8 or was it so it runs windows 8 rt which is the arm based version of windows 8 so you can't just like bring your own applications, your old Windows 95 applications, and just run them. And when you are using it,
这并不明显是一个问题。一切似乎都运行得很好，就像当你能进入小开始菜单时。它稍微有点不同的 Windows 8 差异。但大部分情况下，它只是工作，东西都在那里，而且很好。但它的外形就像，我们处于就像东西都在那里，而且很好。但你知道，它的外形对我来说有点奇怪。就像它的方形纵横比对我来说有点奇怪，就像拿着它一样。
it's not obvious that that's actually a problem. Everything just seems to work just like when you can get to the little start menu. It's slightly different Windows 8 differences. But for the most part, it just worked, and stuff is there, and it was nice. But the form factor of it is like, we're in like stuff is there and it was nice. But you know, the form factor of it is a little bit strange to me. Like the squareness aspect ratio of it is a little bit strange to me, like holding it.
但也许那只是因为我有一个 iPad。所以我习惯了 iPad 的比例。所以这只是不同的东西。键盘，打字很不错。所以键盘怎么样，给我们一个心理……好吧，所以有一个，我的意思是，大多数人可以去网上看。
But maybe that's just because I have an iPad. So I'm used to like the iPad ratio. So it's just something different. The keyboard was, it's pretty nice to type on. So how does the keyboard like, give us a mental- Okay, so there's like a, I mean, most people can go look on the internet.
看它更容易。它比 iPad 稍微长方形一点，所以就像，你知道，背面有一个小支架可以翻出来，所以它可以自己站立，然后它有盖子折叠下来，上面有按键。哦，明白了，明白了，然后你可以在上面打字，而且，他们有两个版本，一个是触摸打字，一个是实际有机械按键的。哦，所以你有触觉反馈。是的，所以它实际上，你知道，相当不错，有几次我们玩的时候，所以是我哥哥和我尝试东西，看起来它没有注册我们的点击，但你知道，我在网上看到一些报道，人们说那也发生在他们身上，就像它只注册了一半点击，就像动画
It's much easier to see it. It's slightly more rectangular than the ipad so like you know the back has a little kickstand that flips out so it stands on its own and then it has the cover folds down and has keys on it oh got it got it and then you can type on it and um they have two versions one that's like a touch typing and one that has like actual kind of mechanical keys oh so you get the haptic feedback yeah so so it's actually you know it was pretty nice there was a couple like instances where we were playing around so it's my brother and i were trying stuff like and it seemed like it wasn't registering our clicks but you know and i've seen some reports on the internet about people saying like that also happened to them like it kind of only half registers the click like the animation
播放了，但没有发生应该发生的底层反馈。但这也是其中之一，就像我第一次拿到 iPad 时，我完全就像，啊，那没用。就像我不能滑动解锁。就像发生了什么？就像我花了一分钟才有点，
plays but not the underlying feedback of what's supposed to happen. But also it's one of those things, like when I first got my iPad, I was completely like, ah, that's not working. Like I can't slide it to unlock. Like what's going on? Like it took me a minute to get kind of,
哦，你需要按住，就像在按钮下方或上方，就像，你知道，某种，你必须塑造你的大脑以正确的方式工作。所以，你知道，它，是的，相当不错。你知道，它，你可以某种方式，几乎，也许
oh, you need to hold, like get just below the button or just above, like, you know, kind of what, you have to mold your brain to kind of work in the right way. So, you know, it was, yeah, it's pretty nice. You know, it's a, you can kind of work in the right way. So, you know, it was pretty nice. You can kind of, in some ways, almost, maybe
作为一种借口，你想说它是第一版，对吧？这是他们做的第一件事。从开发者角度来看它如何工作？你，我猜你在 Visual Studio 或什么东西里构建？是的，我没有像我应该研究的那样研究它来开始谈论它。我认为基本上有
as a cop-out, you want to say it's a version one, right? It's the first thing that they've done. How does it work from a developer standpoint? Do you, I guess you build in Visual Studio or something? Yeah, I haven't studied it as much as I probably should have to start talking about it. I think there's essentially
Windows 8 SDK，什么的，等价物，对吧？然后你基本上可以为任何一个平台构建。而且我肯定如果你正在开发一个新应用程序，使用 ARM 处理器上可能可用的有限子集的东西可能相当直接，对吧？所以你可以相当无缝地为两者开发。酷。
Windows 8 SDK, whatever, equivalent, right? And then you essentially can build for either platform. And I'm sure if you're developing a new app, it's probably fairly straightforward to use the limited subset of things that are available maybe on the ARM process, right? So you can just develop for both pretty seamlessly. Cool.
但然后可能有一些功能只有当你进入完整的 Windows 8 堆栈或什么时才可用。所以那相当不错。所以我过去尝试了 iPad Mini。所以拥有完整的 iPad 去 iPad Mini。所以我有一个 Nexus 7，Nexus 7 比 iPad Mini 便宜得多。它便宜了 100 美元。
But then there might be certain features that are only available when you go to the full Windows 8 stack or whatever. So that's pretty nice. So then I went over and tried the iPad Mini. So having the full iPad going to the iPad Mini. So I have a Nexus 7, and the Nexus 7 is much cheaper than the iPad Mini. It's $100 cheaper.
iPad Mini 大小差不多，对吧？所以我猜它和 Nexus 7 大小差不多，除了屏幕占用了更多的空间。哦，明白了。所以，就像，屏幕更大。而且纵横比稍微不同。所以你想向我们展示你很棒的 Nexus 7 吗？哦，这是我的 Nexus 7。
The iPad Mini is about the same size, right? So I guess it's about the same size as the Nexus 7, except that the screen takes up more of the real estate. Oh, gotcha. So, like, the screen is bigger. And the aspect ratio is slightly different. So you want to show us your awesome Nexus 7? Oh, this is my Nexus 7.
哦，音频里的人不会像，发生了什么？那是它的背面。这是正面。哦，太棒了。哦，好吧。那是时间。我想，哦，是的。
Oh, people on the audio won't be like, what's going on? That's the back of it. This is the front. Oh, pretty awesome. Oh, okay. There's the time. I think, oh, yep.
时间相当棒。时间相当准确。COLTON OGDEN 精确到分钟。COLTON OGDEN 是的。COLTON OGDEN 是的。
Time is pretty awesome. Time is pretty accurate. COLTON OGDEN Down to the minute. COLTON OGDEN Yeah. COLTON OGDEN Yeah.
所以它怎么比较？COLTON OGDEN 但它并不引人注目。对于它贵了多少，它就像，你知道，如果你，所以对我来说，第一世界问题，这就是他们所说的，对吧？就像我有一个 iPad，我有一个 iPhone，我有一个 Nexus 7，我有一台笔记本电脑，我有一台台式机，我拥有整个频谱。就像如果我只是拿 iPhone 或者我以前用过 Android 手机，这也，
So how does it compare? COLTON OGDEN But it wasn't compelling. For how much more expensive it was, it was just like, you know, if you, so for me, the first world problem, is that what they call it, right? Like I have an iPad, I have an iPhone, I have a Nexus 7, I have a laptop, I have a desktop, and I have all the spectrum. It's like if I just take like iPhone or I've used an Android phone before and this also,
你知道，对我来说相当等价，你知道，只是有一些微妙的原因我选择了其中一个而不是另一个。然后拥有一个平板电脑，我确实认为当我拿到我的 iPad 时，已经快两年了，当时我觉得它比竞争对手的平板电脑好得多。现在它稍微平衡了一些。但然后拥有中间那个有点像，呃。所以如果你要买一个中间尺寸的，所以我用它就像电子阅读器一样，对吧，而不是 Nook 或 Kindle 之类的，嗯，那个中间
you know, fairly equivalent to me, you know, just Just some subtle reasons why I chose one over the other. And then having a tablet, which I do think for when I got my iPad, which has been almost two years now, is that at that time, I felt like it was much better than the competing tablets. Now it's a little more even. But then having that middle one is kind of like, eh. so if you're gonna get a middle size one so i use it kind of like as an e-reader right instead of a nook or a kindle or something um that middle
尺寸的很好，但你不想付很多钱，是的，因为你只会用它，就像如果我移动，我用我的手机，如果我放松，你知道在家里，我用我的大屏幕，我的平板电脑更适合网页浏览。所以它只是像在车里，在机场，对吧？就像几个，你知道，就像带它去工作会议，当我不想携带一个大的，就像那种东西。事情是中间那个适合。有点有趣的是，我多年来已经看到了我们的转变。
size one is nice but you don't want to pay a lot yeah because you're only going to use it's like if i'm mobile mobile i'm using my phone if i'm relaxed you know at home i'm using my my big screen my tablet is much better for web viewing. So it's only like in the car, at the airport, right? Like a few, you know, like taking it around to work meetings when I don't want to have to carry a big, like that kind of stuff. The thing is the middle one fits. The thing that's kind of funny is I've sort of seen over the years our transformation.
所以我记得我在想，哦，我永远不会真正使用智能手机。现在就像我会在放弃智能手机之前砍掉我的手臂。而且就像，哦，你知道，iPad。你记得辩论。我记得辩论买智能手机。就像，哦，我想要一个付费数据计划并拥有互联网热点。太贵了。我会用它吗？
So I remember I was thinking, oh, I'd never really use a smartphone. And now it's like I chop off my arm before I'd give up my smartphone. And it was like, oh, you know, an iPad. You remember debating. I remember debating getting a smartphone. Like, oh, I want a paid data plan and have the internet hot. So expensive. Will I use it?
哦，是的。是的，现在就像每一分钟。然后我记得当我们谈论 iPad 时，在非常早期的剧集之一，我们就像，哦，我不知道平板电脑，就像，真的有意义吗。现在就像我们使用平板电脑，在非常早期的剧集之一谈论 iPad。我们就像，哦，我不知道平板电脑真的有意义吗。现在就像我们一直使用平板电脑。这真的是对你作为硬件开发者必须有多大胆的证明。你必须制造没人认为他们想要的东西。然后说服人们他们想要它。
Oh, yeah. Yeah, now it's like every minute. And then I remember when we were talking about the iPad on one of the very first episodes, we were like, oh, I don't know if the tablet, like, really makes sense. And now it's like we use tablets about the iPad on one of the very first episodes. We were like, oh, I don't know if the tablet really makes sense. And now it's like we use tablets all the time. It's really a testament to how audacious you have to be as a hardware developer. You have to make something that nobody thinks they want. And then convince people they want it.
是的，然后让人们的生活方式以适合该设备的方式适应。任何这些东西变得像现在这样广泛，这真的很神奇。是的。哦，所以播客的人，播客的听众可能记得我对 Kickstarter 有几次咆哮。我并不像很多人那样支持 Kickstarter。我以为你超级支持 Kickstarter。真的吗？我被指责为反 Kickstarter。
Yeah, and then have people's lifestyle adapt in a way that fits that device. It's really amazing that any of this stuff gets as widespread as it is. Yeah. Oh, so people of the podcast, listeners of the podcast may remember I have several rants against Kickstarter. I'm not as pro-Kickstarter as a lot of people. I thought you were super pro-Kickstarter. Really? I get accused of being like anti-Kickstarter.
是的，然后让人们的生活方式以适应那种设备的方式进行调整。任何这些东西能像现在这样普及，真的很令人惊奇。是啊。哦，所以播客的听众可能还记得我曾多次抨击Kickstarter。我并不像很多人那样支持Kickstarter。我以为你非常支持Kickstarter。真的吗？我常被指责为反Kickstarter派。
I remember you ranting about this. I'm I get accused of being anti-Kickstarter. I remember you ranting about this stuff. I'm like kind of, I straddled the fence. So I did see, which you know, it's anecdotal, right? So it's not proof. But they had this really awesome iPhone dock. I think it was called the Elevation Dock or whatever. It was this really slick machined iPhone dock. It's like really easy to put your iPhone down in and it would charge it. It had like an audio out port as an option
记得你之前抱怨过这个。我总是被指责反众筹。我记得你抱怨过这些东西。我算是那种骑墙派吧。所以我确实看到过，你知道，这只是轶事，对吧？所以它不是证据。但他们有一个非常棒的 iPhone 底座。我想它叫 Elevation Dock 之类的。那是一个非常精巧的机加工 iPhone 底座。把 iPhone 放进去充电非常容易。它还有一个音频输出端口作为选项。
It was just really really nice like really high-end design, right? Yeah, so you would have bought it like over 12 months ago, and it was supposed to ship I'm gonna mess with the exact days on it in front of me, but like April right So it didn't end up shipping until like only like four or five weeks ago So like let's call it five four or five months late six months late on top of it You would have paid a fairly good price I believe like the cheaper ones were you know still like I want to say like $75 type of range I'm probably wrong on that but um that kind of range as pretty nice, but all is nice, right?
它真的非常好，是非常高端的设计，对吧？是的，你可能在 12 个月前就买了它，它本应该在——我可能会记错具体的日期——大概是四月发货吧？结果直到四五周前才发货。所以算它晚了四五个月，甚至六个月。而且你还付了相当高的价格，我相信便宜的款式也要，你知道，大概 75 美元左右。我可能记错了，但大概是那个范围，虽然东西很好，但还是挺让人心烦的，对吧？
They didn't end up shipping which just could have happened at any time, but they delayed they didn't they got way more orders And they thought whatever right they delayed it was a very profitable Kickstarter They they ship sold a lot of them. And then right before, when they finally shipped, some people got their Docks literally the day before they got their iPhone 5s, which changed the Dock connector. Oh, no. Are you serious? So some people were getting them who bought iPhone 5s. Well, arguably, if you're buying a nice Dock, you're a, you know, you really like the iPhone. You're using it. You probably upgrade. And then, like, you're buying a nice dock, you're a, you know, you really like the
他们没能按时发货，这随时都可能发生，但他们推迟了，他们收到的订单远超预期，不管怎样，他们推迟了。那是一个非常赚钱的众筹项目，他们卖出了很多。然后在他们终于发货之前，有些人收到底座的第二天就拿到了 iPhone 5，而 iPhone 5 更换了底座接口。哦，不。你是认真的吗？所以有些人买到手时，他们已经换了 iPhone 5。好吧，可以说，如果你买一个好的底座，你肯定很喜欢 iPhone，你一直在用它。你很可能会升级。然后，你买了一个好的底座，你……
iPhone you're using, you probably upgrade. And then, like, you're buying it and it's, like, obsolete. It's like, ah. So I saw that. I felt so bad for this. Yeah, so they changed the dock connector in the most recent one. I wonder why. A lot of reasons, but we won't get into it right now. I mean, it makes sense. I'm not faulting Apple for doing it or whatever.
你正在用的 iPhone，你很可能会升级。然后，你买了它，它就过时了。就像是，啊。所以我看到了。我为这些人感到难过。是的，他们在最新款上更换了底座接口。我不知道为什么。原因很多，但我们现在不讨论这个。我的意思是，这说得通。我并不是在指责苹果这样做之类的。
But just another one of those Kickstarter things. You're not buying it today. You're pre-buying something that's going to be made then it might slip and then you finally get it it's like it's already obsolete versus like you know if you knew you were going to buy the iphone and you saw that in the store like let's say you know the target or walmart right you were gonna you knew you were gonna buy the iphone 5 you might wait before buying it because you know you're gonna buy the new iphone and and there's rumors that it might be changing. But back when people bought this thing, there were no rumors that the iPhone dock would be changing.
但这只是众筹的又一个问题。你不是今天买它。你是在预购一个在那时才会制造的东西，它可能会延期，当你最终拿到它时，它已经过时了。相比之下，如果你知道你要买 iPhone，并且你在商店里看到了它，比如在塔吉特或沃尔玛，你知道你要买 iPhone 5，你可能会在购买前等待，因为你知道你要买新 iPhone，而且有传言说接口可能会改变。但在人们购买这个东西的时候，还没有关于 iPhone 底座会改变的传言。
Yeah, totally. I don't think so anyways. You have to invest so far in advance and technology changes so quickly. I'll still go for board games though. Board game kickstarters? Pretty timeless. Well, I could get into some negativity on that too but I have the one
是的，完全同意。反正我不这么认为。你必须提前投入那么多，而技术变化太快了。不过我还是会选择桌游。桌游众筹？相当经典。好吧，我也可以对此发表一些负面看法，但我有一个……
I ordered it did turn out well and it is nice there you go which one did you order what is it called for the wind I haven't heard of that one for the wind so it's like a abstract tile laying game about pirates ninjas zombies amazing and one other what is the monkeys
我订购的那个结果还不错，而且确实很好，你看，就是这样。你订购的是哪一个？它叫什么名字？For the Win。我没听说过那个。For the Win，所以它是一个关于海盗、忍者、僵尸的抽象拼图游戏，太棒了，还有一个是什么？猴子？
amazing I think and so it's the tile abstract thing and you play, each one has like a special effect and allows you to flip over the tile or not. And so it's kind of, it's pretty good. It was a good deal. So I've enjoyed that. All right, so is it time for viewer questions?
太棒了，我想是这样。所以它是一个抽象拼图游戏，你玩的时候，每一个都有特殊效果，允许你翻转拼图或者不翻转。所以它还不错。这是一个不错的交易。所以我很喜欢它。好了，现在是观众提问时间了吗？
I think it is. Let's get to viewer questions. So we had a good response. We had a lot of people sending questions. Yeah, yeah, thank you guys for the questions. Pretty awesome. You have a lot of people sending questions. Yeah, yeah. Thank you guys for the questions. Pretty awesome. You have high quality, great questions. And sound effects, pretty awesome. So let's just get straight to the mailbag.
我想是的。让我们开始观众提问吧。我们收到了很好的反馈。很多人发来了问题。是的，是的，感谢大家的提问。太棒了。你们有很多人发来问题。是的，是的。感谢大家的提问。太棒了。你们的问题质量很高，非常棒。还有音效，太棒了。所以让我们直接进入邮件箱环节。
So we'll kind of mix up some questions from the audience and some questions from the mailbag. Okay, yeah. So if you have a question and you're on the hangout right now because we do have some live listeners so we have like three or three people four people um and if you have a question just type it into the chat box and uh we'll either like have you read it out loud or read the question yeah definitely so yeah type your question out in the chat box plus that will keep us from answering your question with like without knowing it's you and you have to ask the question again that's super weird so yeah if you have your question go ahead
所以我们会混合一些来自观众的问题和一些来自邮件箱的问题。好的，没问题。所以如果你有一个问题，并且你现在正在参加我们的视频群聊，因为我们确实有一些直播听众，大概有三四个人，如果你有问题，只需在聊天框里输入，我们会让你大声读出来，或者我们来读这个问题。是的，绝对可以。所以，在聊天框里输入你的问题，这样可以避免我们在不知道是你问的情况下回答你的问题，然后你又得再问一遍，那太奇怪了。所以，如果你有问题，请继续。
and like copy it from your email and like paste it into the into the chat from the hangout so that we know not to ask it because we have actually all the questions from the email here so the first question is from and I really apologize if I butcher your name but I I'm going to try my best. It's from Marco Aurelio da Silva Saraiva. And he's from Brazil, I believe. Yes, I got it right. It's a very Brazilian name.
从你的邮件里复制它，然后粘贴到群聊的聊天框里，这样我们就知道不要问它了，因为我们这里已经有了邮件里的所有问题。所以第一个问题来自——如果我念错了你的名字，我深表歉意，但我会尽力而为。它来自 Marco Aurelio da Silva Saraiva。我相信他来自巴西。是的，我念对了。这是一个非常典型的巴西名字。
So he's from Brazil. He says, listening to you guys every episode, and it's been amazing. Thanks a lot. So he wants to know how internet crawlers work. So how web crawling works. So I guess I could take this one. Okay. So the way most internet crawlers work is they typically start with a seed set of websites.
所以他来自巴西。他说，每一集都听你们的节目，非常棒。非常感谢。所以他想知道互联网爬虫是如何工作的。也就是网络爬虫是如何工作的。我想我可以回答这个问题。好的。大多数互联网爬虫的工作方式是，它们通常从一组种子网站开始。
And so with most of these crawlers like google and bing and things like that you can actually submit your website so you can actually tell like google bing yahoo whatever like you know i have this website and you should add it to your list of seed sites so it goes through these seed sites and and for each one of these sites, it scrapes all the HTML, puts it in a reverse index, which I'll explain later, and then also finds all of the tags and then adds it to this queue. So in the beginning, the queue just has the seed websites in it. So that would be stuff people submitted on their own, but also like hub sites, like Wikipedia or sites that link to a lot of other sites. Yep, totally.
对于大多数像谷歌、必应之类的爬虫，你实际上可以提交你的网站，你可以告诉谷歌、必应、雅虎之类的，你知道，我有这个网站，你应该把它加到你的种子网站列表中。所以它会遍历这些种子网站，对于每一个网站，它会抓取所有的 HTML，把它放入一个反向索引中（我稍后会解释），然后还会找到所有的标签，并把它们加到队列中。起初，队列里只有种子网站。所以那可能是人们自己提交的网站，也包括像维基百科这样的中心网站，或者链接到很多其他网站的网站。是的，完全正确。
So yeah, so it'll have like Wikipedia, AOL.com, Yahoo.com, et cetera. And so you can imagine this queue that has all these websites on it. And the system will go, pick one of the websites off the queue, and then it'll store that HTML somewhere and any images and things like that and then for all the links it'll add that to the back of the queue and then it'll keep pulling web pages off and then adding more on you can imagine this queue getting really really really big you know of course there's all sorts of what's called stemming which is for example
所以是的，它会有像维基百科、AOL.com、Yahoo.com 等等。你可以想象这个队列里有所有这些网站。系统会从队列中取出一个网站，然后把它的 HTML 存储在某个地方，包括任何图片之类的，然后对于所有的链接，它会把它们加到队列的末尾，然后它会不断地从队列中取出网页，再添加更多的网页。你可以想象这个队列变得非常非常大。当然，还有各种所谓的“词干提取”（stemming），例如……
let's say you're but you know sometimes you go like on youtube for example you go and you search for something and there's like a million results and you could just keep paging through right so a stemming will know that oh this is really just millions and millions of these like results but it's it's just kind of like a search query and i don't really need to scan these like it doesn't really make sense for me to scan these. So it'll stop there. So it's not going to go forever. The stemming will make sure that you'll eventually run out of pages.
假设你……你知道，有时你去 YouTube 搜索东西，会有上百万个结果，你可以一直翻页，对吧？所以词干提取会知道，哦，这实际上只是数以百万计的结果，但这只是一个搜索查询，我真的不需要扫描这些，扫描这些没什么意义。所以它会在那里停止。所以它不会永远运行下去。词干提取会确保你最终会用完页面。
So this queue keeps growing and shrinking. And then finally, when the queue's down to zero, you have- DAN GALPIN- It also marks. Because you can have it with cycles. So it has to mark and know who it's already visited. DAN GALPIN- That's right. So when something gets pushed off the queue, it gets put onto some key, some hash set somewhere,
所以这个队列不断增长和缩小。最后，当队列归零时，你有——DAN GALPIN：它还会做标记。因为你可能会遇到循环。所以它必须标记并知道它已经访问过哪些网站。DAN GALPIN：没错。所以当某个东西从队列中移出时，它会被放入某个键，某个哈希集合中，
which just says, yeah, this is visited. So eventually the queue gets down to zero. And the other thing is that this is distributed, right? So there's this queue, but you're not going to each one of these websites like on a single computer you're pulling things off of the queue and then sending them to other computers and then they're like going pulling all the images and stuff and then they're just like telling you like what new things add to the queue so you know it sounds like this would take forever but if you have like a ton of machines you know well no i mean it basically i mean it can grow faster than
上面写着，是的，这个已经访问过了。所以最终队列归零。另一件事是，这是分布式的，对吧？所以有这个队列，但你不是在单台计算机上访问每一个网站，你从队列中取出东西，然后把它们发送到其他计算机，然后它们去抓取所有的图片之类的，然后它们只是告诉你有什么新东西要加到队列里。所以你知道，听起来这需要永远的时间，但如果你有大量的机器，你知道……不，我的意思是，它基本上……它增长的速度可能比……
you could process it in some ways. That's true. Depending on, like, what your scale of processing is. So you just limit it to some time or, you know, probabilistically you're going to visit the most popular websites will have the most links. So you'll kind of get them early on. Yep. And the other thing, too, is you don't want to completely cream some, like, I run my personal website where i have like hobby projects and like that well like some search engine like bing or something like hits all of my web pages all at the same time and like downloads all of the images like it'll completely crush my computer right so
你处理它的速度还要快。这是真的。取决于你的处理规模。所以你只是把它限制在一定时间内，或者，你知道，从概率上讲，你会访问最受欢迎的网站，因为它们会有最多的链接。所以你会很早就得到它们。是的。另一件事是，你不想完全搞垮某个网站，比如我运行我的个人网站，上面有一些业余项目，如果像必应这样的搜索引擎同时访问我所有的网页，并下载所有的图片，它会完全搞垮我的电脑，所以……
they're pretty clever about you know you know like like oh i just went to this computer let's put this one back in the queue don't process it right now and so there's all sorts of clever details there okay so now you have a ton of these pages and you have like think of it as a huge map where the key is the URL and the value is all of this HTML and what you want is for somebody else to say type in so in this case Marcos he actually wants to make a magic the gathering like like subnet so yeah he actually wants to make a Magic the Gathering subnet. So he wants to have all his Magic the Gathering data that he's mined from the internet. So if you were to do this, Marco, and somebody types in, I don't know, ethereal dragon. I'm trying to remember my
他们很聪明，你知道，比如“哦，我刚访问过这台电脑，让我们把它放回队列，现在不要处理它”，所以这里面有很多巧妙的细节。好的，现在你有了大量的页面，你可以把它想象成一张巨大的地图，键是 URL，值是所有的 HTML。你想要的是让别人输入——在这种情况下，Marcos 他实际上想做一个万智牌（Magic the Gathering）的子网——所以是的，他实际上想做一个万智牌子网。所以他想拥有他从互联网上挖掘到的所有万智牌数据。所以如果你要这样做，Marco，如果有人输入，我不知道，以太龙（Ethereal Dragon）。我正在努力回忆我的……
Magic the Gathering cards. Or phantom lancer. I don't remember. Anyways, so if someone types in one of the Magic the Gathering cards, you would want to pull up all the pages that have that name in it. And so that's what a reverse index does. So a reverse index is essentially a way where you can put in a word, and it'll give you all of the values, all of the documents that have that word in it. And there's a whole bunch of crazy information theory, information theoretic things that you can do you can actually um if you have the documents arranged in such a way like if all the documents for one server are together then you can actually with 99.9 accuracy um create a reverse index without
万智牌卡片。或者幻影枪兵（Phantom Lancer）。我不记得了。总之，如果有人输入其中一张万智牌卡片，你会想要调出所有包含该名称的页面。这就是反向索引的作用。所以反向索引本质上是一种方式，你可以输入一个词，它会给你所有的值，即所有包含该词的文档。还有一大堆疯狂的信息论知识，你可以做一些事情……如果你把文档以某种方式排列，比如如果一个服务器的所有文档都在一起，那么你实际上可以以 99.9% 的准确率创建反向索引，而无需……
scanning all the documents so you know it's true that like this guy's website on antique cars might have magic the gathering, but it probably doesn't. And if you scan five pages and it's all antique cars, and you know there's like a very low correlation between that and ethereal dragons, then you can just skip his entire website. And so building the reverse index
扫描所有的文档。所以你知道，虽然这个人的古董车网站可能包含万智牌的内容，但它很可能没有。如果你扫描了五个页面，发现全是古董车，而且你知道那和以太龙之间的相关性非常低，那么你就可以直接跳过他的整个网站。所以构建反向索引……
is all sorts of cleverness there, too. So there are also, I mean, people have already written web crawlers that you can use in various languages, which is really nice. Yeah, totally. And also, and I'm trying to find it now on the fly, we didn't do a lot of prep going through the questions
里面也有各种巧妙之处。所以，人们已经编写了可以用多种语言使用的网络爬虫，这真的很棒。是的，完全正确。而且，我正在努力即时找到它，我们没有做太多的准备来浏览这些问题……
and answering as well as we could have. But there's also, if you search for like, web crawling and Amazon EC2, there are articles where people have written about how they do it. And now you get into cost, right? So you spin up an EC2 instance, so you might have to pay for that. But there might be also data stores.
并尽可能好地回答它们。但如果你搜索像“网络爬虫”和“亚马逊 EC2”，有一些文章是人们写的关于他们如何做这件事的。现在你涉及到了成本，对吧？所以你启动一个 EC2 实例，你可能需要为此付费。但可能还有数据存储。
Other people have already done the web crawling part, which is intensive and expensive. And you can essentially just use the data. So they'll create some data store. And then you can just process that data store. So at least you save yourself half the effort. CHRIS CARTLAND- One that's really great is called Common Crawl.
其他人已经完成了网络爬虫的部分，这是密集且昂贵的。你基本上可以直接使用这些数据。所以他们会创建一个数据存储。然后你就可以直接处理那个数据存储。所以至少你省了一半的力气。CHRIS CARTLAND：有一个非常棒的叫 Common Crawl。
Highly recommended. Basically, it's a totally open source reverse index of the internet. And so I think it even has images and things like that. So Marco, Aurelio, check out Common Crawl. And that way, you don't have to do that part. You can just take advantage of the index they've already built.
强烈推荐。基本上，它是一个完全开源的互联网反向索引。所以我认为它甚至还有图片之类的。所以 Marco Aurelio，去看看 Common Crawl。这样，你就不必做那部分工作了。你可以直接利用他们已经建立的索引。
MARK MIRCHANDANI- But inevitably, this is one of those things you find out is really hard to do. DAN GALPINI- Yeah. It's super, super hard. MARK MIRCHANDANI- It's actually super, super hard. And if you look at Bing or Google or Yahoo, how much money they're spending trying to do this quickly and accurately, because websites change, and they go down,
MARK MIRCHANDANI：但不可避免地，这是你发现做起来非常困难的事情之一。DAN GALPIN：是的。这超级超级难。MARK MIRCHANDANI：这确实超级超级难。如果你看看必应、谷歌或雅虎，他们花了多少钱试图快速准确地做到这一点，因为网站在变化，它们会宕机，
and links come up, and links go down. know it's just it's a really really big mess and so a lot of time and money is spent by really big companies to do this really well so depending on what you try to do sometimes it is just is not feasible for an individual you know without a good profit reason for doing it to actually do it yeah i. I mean, you know, I think they said on the Common Crawl website that just going through and looking up the number of times a word is there, like if you want to see how many times the word does on the internet, that'll basically cost you like a hundred dollars, like an Amazon easy to use it. So, um, this would be an expensive hobby, but, um, it can be done. It can totally be done. And it can be done in a matter of days, which
链接会出现，链接会消失。你知道，这真是一个非常非常大的烂摊子，所以大公司花了很多时间和金钱来把这件事做好。所以根据你尝试做的事情，有时对于个人来说，如果没有好的盈利理由，这确实是不可行的。是的，我的意思是，你知道，我想他们在 Common Crawl 网站上说过，仅仅是遍历并查找一个词出现的次数，比如如果你想看看“does”这个词在互联网上出现了多少次，那基本上会花费你一百美元，用亚马逊 EC2 的话。所以，这会是一个昂贵的爱好，但是，它是可以做到的。它完全可以做到。而且可以在几天内完成，这……
is pretty amazing. So Common Crawl has all their source code available online. So I also believe that Sebastian Thrun, am I saying that right? I think we've talked about him before on here. He does one of those massively multiplayer? No, no, massively whatever online learning things. Oh, oh.
非常令人惊奇。所以 Common Crawl 把他们所有的源代码都在线提供了。我也相信 Sebastian Thrun——我念对了吗？我想我们之前在这里谈论过他。他做了一个大规模多人在线……不，不，大规模什么的在线学习课程。哦，哦。
And so he did two, I believe. One in how to create create a search engine and one in how to create an autonomous car it's like you know the the kind of uh the background behind that and i believe that one about creating a search engine i would assume talks about web crawling at least at some level so that might be something else to check it out i'm trying to bring it up now and i'm not seeing it exactly um but yeah so i would definitely check out um if there's like oh udacity is the name of his platform yeah that's right and so i believe one of his is like how to write a search engine i don't know if it is applicable to this or not but i um i would check it out because that might have a lot of really good information okay cool so let's take one yeah let's take one. Yeah, let's take one from the... Here we go.
我相信他做了两个。一个是关于如何创建搜索引擎，一个是关于如何创建自动驾驶汽车。这就像是，你知道，背后的背景知识。我相信那个关于创建搜索引擎的课程，我假设至少在某种程度上谈到了网络爬虫，所以那可能是另一个值得查看的东西。我正在努力调出它，但我没有确切地看到它……但是的，所以我一定会去看看，如果有什么……哦，Udacity 是他的平台名称。是的，没错。我相信他的其中一个课程是“如何编写搜索引擎”。我不知道它是否适用于此，但我……我会去看看，因为它可能有很多非常好的信息。好的，酷，那我们选一个吧。是的，选一个。是的，选一个……我们开始吧。
From our live viewers. And I'll read it off and you answer. Okay, all right. Oh, yeah, this is a great question. So this is from Aaron Chapman. And let me see. I actually have this Chapman. He's from Eastern Alabama.
来自我们的直播观众。我来读，你来回答。好的，没问题。哦，是的，这是一个很好的问题。这是来自 Aaron Chapman 的。让我看看。我确实有这个 Chapman。他来自阿拉巴马州东部。
So hey, Aaron from Eastern Alabama.ama um cool so it says i love everything apple i've written five iphone apps on the app store study objective c and coco touch constantly and i find it difficult to continue doing this because there's no one near me that's interested in programming i'd be happy to learn other languages but there isn't anyone near me so so the general gist of the question is sort of is, how can you get into a hobby like software engineering, programming, this kind of making apps, these kind of things, when nobody in your physical vicinity is into it? Yeah, so there's a couple of different ways. So one is these massively online learning platforms often have forums.
所以嘿，阿拉巴马州东部的 Aaron。酷，他说我热爱苹果的一切，我在 App Store 上写了五个 iPhone 应用，不断学习 Objective-C 和 Cocoa Touch，但我发现很难继续这样做，因为我附近没有人对编程感兴趣。我很乐意学习其他语言，但附近没有人。所以问题的核心是，当你的物理邻近范围内没有人对软件工程、编程、制作应用这些东西感兴趣时，你该如何进入这个爱好？是的，有几种不同的方法。一种是这些大规模在线学习平台通常有论坛。
And so you already know that people in some, if there's one that's in that domain, right, that they're like iPhone development, I'm sure there's probably some, you'll probably find that there are people there who are also posting in the forum and just kind of like start chatting with them. If you have ideas for things, try to say like, hey, you know, I have this, I'm sure there's an area devoted, like, hey have this idea like anybody want to you know work on this with me or whatever the other thing i would recommend is um trying to find open source people doing something similar totally so for mobile development it's a little hard um because
而且你已经知道，如果在这个领域里有人，对吧，比如 iPhone 开发，我敢肯定可能有一些，你可能会发现那里也有人在论坛上发帖，然后就开始和他们聊天。如果你有想法，试着说，嘿，你知道，我有这个想法，我敢肯定有一个专门的区域，比如“嘿，我有这个想法，有人想和我一起做这个吗”之类的。我建议的另一件事是，尝试寻找做类似事情的开源人员。完全正确。所以对于移动开发来说，这有点难，因为……
the open source thing gets a little touchy depending on exactly what you're trying to do yeah like most open source people want to write tools and libraries and things like that, whereas like most apps are kind of end products. But there you might be able to find something in that region, so that would be something else. And then another thing would be like if depending on what you're interested in developing and then what you're trying to learn. So if you're trying to get connected with other people kind of to just work on something together, which is excellent, you know, resume builder for college, you know, admissions
开源的事情根据你具体想做什么会变得有点敏感。是的，大多数开源人员想写工具、库之类的东西，而大多数应用是某种最终产品。但在那个领域你可能能找到一些东西，所以那是另一回事。还有一件事是，取决于你对开发什么感兴趣，以及你试图学习什么。所以如果你试图与其他人建立联系，一起做点什么，这对大学申请、找工作来说是非常好的简历加分项……
for getting a job, you know, you might be able to go to something like if you're interested in game programming, going to a game programming forum and finding people who are on a project to need help. Now you have to be careful is people there may not be as devoted as you are, or maybe more devoted than you're willing to be. So you might have to do some kind of, you know, be just be up front about like what your level of, you know, interest is and how much time you'd be willing to put into it. But you might be able to find like a match, right? So a lot of people are there looking, they have ideas and they're looking for developers. That might be a good match. Or they're, you know, developers looking for other developers, right? So
你可能可以去一些地方，比如如果你对游戏编程感兴趣，去游戏编程论坛，寻找那些正在进行项目并需要帮助的人。现在你必须小心，那里的人可能不像你那么投入，或者可能比你愿意投入的还要投入。所以你可能需要做一些……只是坦诚地说明你的兴趣水平以及你愿意投入多少时间。但你可能能找到匹配的人，对吧？所以很多人在那里寻找，他们有想法，正在寻找开发者。这可能是一个很好的匹配。或者他们是寻找其他开发者的开发者，对吧？所以……
that's another thing to explore. And depending on what niche you're in, yeah, there could be a lot of people interested in that kind of thing. Yeah, of yeah totally i mean so a little anecdote about this is i um when i did a lot of game programming especially when i was younger i just kind of went on my own i didn't really like go to forums didn't really pay much attention so because of that i wasted a lot of time you know like i made it wasn't wasted because it's kind of valuable, but personally, but as from a purpose of making something, it was kind of a waste. Like I spent all this time, you know, dealing with writing things to a file and reading them. Whereas like I could have just used protocol buffers or thrift like we talked about in earlier episode. And I just, I just wasn't a very like efficient programmer.
这是另一个值得探索的方向。取决于你在哪个细分领域，是的，可能会有很多人对那种事情感兴趣。是的，完全同意。关于这一点的一个小轶事是，我……当我做很多游戏编程时，特别是在我年轻的时候，我只是自己一个人做，并没有真正去论坛，也没有太注意，所以因为这个，我浪费了很多时间。你知道，比如我做的东西，虽然不算浪费，因为这很有价值，但就个人而言，从制作东西的目的来看，这是一种浪费。我花了很多时间处理文件读写。而我本可以使用我们之前提到的 Protocol Buffers 或 Thrift。我只是……我不是一个非常高效的程序员。
And on top of that, the even worse thing was that i made things that people didn't want to play and it's like and i had nobody of myself to really go off of you know and so and i'm not even your mom even your mom wouldn't blame no even my mom yeah she started and she was like no she's like she's like this isn't for hardcore players so i'm out she uh but no so it's like i'm not tarn adams i can, so it's, like, I'm not Tarn Adams. I can't just, like, make genius, like, by myself. So it turns out that when I started getting into, like, 3D modeling and more artsy side projects, I got together with, like, Pixel Junk and some other forums,
最糟糕的是，我做的东西人们根本不想玩，而且我没有任何人可以参考。甚至连我妈都不……甚至连我妈都不买账。不，连我妈……是的，她试玩了一下，然后她说，不，她说这不适合硬核玩家，所以我退出了。她……但没有，所以就像我不是 Tarn Adams，我不能……我不能只是自己做出天才的作品。所以事实证明，当我开始接触 3D 建模和更具艺术性的副项目时，我加入了 Pixel Junk 和其他一些论坛，
and I was kind of, like, sharing pictures, and they gave me a ton of feedback. Like, oh, you know, you're doing this totally wrong. Like, you're using this kind of, like, I was using an iconosphere instead of a uv sphere and it became really hard to texture and they're just giving me tons of feedback and that is incredibly useful like now i feel like i can make 3d models like really well interesting yeah that's a good point put your work out there so i was going to mention something similar as well like start a blog right like yeah it seems kind of weird but i mean if you start and and then just start posting like to various you know people that you admire look up to or other people are doing something similar and say like hey you should check out this like
我分享了一些图片，他们给了我大量的反馈。比如，哦，你知道，你完全做错了。比如，你正在使用这种……我当时用的是图标球体而不是 UV 球体，这导致纹理处理变得非常困难，他们给了我大量的反馈，这非常有价值。现在我觉得我可以做出非常好的 3D 模型了。有趣，是的，这是一个好观点，把你的作品展示出来。所以我本来也要提到类似的事情，比如开一个博客，对吧？是的，这看起来有点奇怪，但我的意思是，如果你开始，然后开始发布给各种你钦佩的人，或者其他做类似事情的人，说“嘿，你应该看看这个，
what do you think you have any comments could you like look at this and and critique this for me or whatever right like i mean it's hard to put yourself out there to you know be criticized but you know just remember you're just like learning right like we're all learning like we have to remember that there are always somebody better than us yeah totally and they are on that forum no doubt so yeah i mean just going to a popular forum say hey i made this like anybody have feedback and you'll get some jerks on there right like people like ah this is terrible i mean you got a deal that's the internet right like exactly that's what happens to me every time i try to play a game online oh that's the worst you worst. You're the worst! I actually, I was playing Defense of the Ancients,
你觉得怎么样？你有什么评论吗？你能看看这个并为我批评一下吗？”之类的，对吧？我的意思是，把自己展示出来去接受批评很难，但你知道，记住你只是在学习，对吧？就像我们都在学习一样，我们必须记住总有人比我们更好。是的，完全正确。而且他们毫无疑问就在那个论坛上。所以是的，我的意思是，去一个热门论坛说“嘿，我做了这个，有人有反馈吗”，你会遇到一些混蛋，对吧？比如有人说“啊，这太糟糕了”，我的意思是，你得处理这些，这就是互联网，对吧？没错，这就是我每次尝试在线玩游戏时发生的事情。哦，那是你最糟糕的。你是最差的！我实际上，我当时在玩《DotA》，
which is known for having, like, big-time, like, trolls, and other trolls and things like that. And somebody told me the other day that, like, I should kill myself because, like, I wasn't doing well in the game or whatever. And, like, you know, of course it doesn't matter. But, like, I just, for some reason it, like, resonated. And I thought about it, and I was like, you know, like, this person, like, they'll just say absolutely anything. Like, they don really like, it's not even like, I don't think the person,
它以有很多喷子和喷子之类的而闻名。前几天有人告诉我，我应该去自杀，因为我在游戏里表现不好之类的。而且，你知道，当然这无关紧要。但，就像，我只是，出于某种原因，它引起了共鸣。我想了想，我说，你知道，这个人，他们只是会说任何话。就像，他们并不真正……就像，我不认为那个人，
like what he's saying is even going through his head. You know what I mean? Like it's going through a part of the brain that just like blurts out, you know what I mean? Like doesn't actually think about it. That's a shame. So you'll get, you'll get all kinds if you go to forums, but you know, a couple of forums I've been to um i've been to tig source tig source which is a game developer yeah yeah and they also have artists uh forums if you're into games yeah that would be also really like the independent but also the ones where they do like 72 hour thing right like oh yeah develop a game in 72 hours right yeah yeah yeah totally and then you submit it and people review it like they have a judge panel or popular
他所说的话甚至经过了他的大脑。你知道我的意思吗？就像它经过了大脑中只会脱口而出的部分，你知道我的意思吗？就像并没有真正思考它。那太遗憾了。所以如果你去论坛，你会遇到各种各样的人，但你知道，我去过几个论坛，我去过 TIGSource，TIGSource 是一个游戏开发者论坛，是的，是的，如果你喜欢游戏，他们也有艺术家论坛，那也会非常……独立开发者，还有那些他们做 72 小时挑战的地方，对吧？哦，是的，在 72 小时内开发一个游戏，对吧？是的，是的，完全正确，然后你提交它，人们会评论它，他们有评审团或大众投票之类的，人们会给你反馈。是的，还有另一件事是，你意识到，哇，这家伙一天就做了一个完整的游戏，而我才刚刚让我的代码编译通过。Ludum Dare。是叫这个名字吗？是的，没错。Ludum Dare？是的，去看看那个。
vote or whatever and people will give you feedback. Yeah, and that's the other thing too is you realize, wow, this guy made an entire game in a day, and I like got my code to compile. Ludum Dare. Is that what it's called? Yeah, that's right. Ludum Dare? Yeah, check that out.
所以，是的，你从中学到了很多非常有趣的事情。所以，是的，希望这能给你一些建议，Aaron。好的，我这里还有另一个问题。好的。所以我们会尽量尊重这里面的名字，但“嗨，我叫 Brian，来自底特律地区”。不错。我喜欢这个播客。
So, yeah, you learn a lot of really interesting things from that. So, yeah, hopefully that gives you some advice, Aaron. All right, so I had another question here. Okay. So we'll try to respect the names that are in here, but hi, my name is Brian from the Detroit area. Nice. I love the podcast.
好的，也许我们不读了。当我们读的时候，听起来真的很像是在自我吹捧……引用，引用，空气引号，Brian，也就是 Jason。不，我们开玩笑的。好的，所以他的问题不是关于技术的，但他是在征求我们的意见。所以他还在上高中。他的 GPA 很好，他有几个朋友
Okay, maybe we won't read. It sounds like really like self-patting on the back when we read the... Quote, unquote, air quotes, Brian, a.k.a. Jason. No, we're just kidding. Okay, so his question isn't really about technology, but he's asking for our opinion. So he's in high school. He's got a good GPA, and he's got several friends
在学校的压力下表现得不太好。他在做研究，他发现当前的学校系统是为了让学生为工厂工作做准备。所以这就像是一个——我在互联网上看到过关于这个的视频。这本意是一种行业。我们会去工厂工作，领取养老金，退休，就像整个这一套。然后那种范式正在改变。朝九晚五。
who aren't really doing well with all the pressures of doing school. And he's doing research, and he discovered that the current school system is meant to prepare the students for basically a factory job. So this is like a – I've seen videos about this on the internet. Like this was meant to be a trade. We would go to work in a factory, get a pension, retire, like this whole thing. And then that paradigm is changing. The nine to five.
是的。他们本意是这样学习的，因为这就是工厂的方式。而现在我们是知识工作者。这不同。你会听到那个术语。所以他说这对我祖父来说非常完美，他在工厂工作。但鉴于不再有工厂工作了，至少在美国是这样，
Yeah. And they were meant to learn this way because this is the way the factory was. And now we're knowledge workers. This is different. You'll hear that term. So it says this worked perfectly for my grandfather who worked in a factory. But seeing as there are no more factory jobs, at least in the United States,
它真的还应该那样设置吗？学校是否应该改变以跟随人们实际会从事的职业？所以这是我实际上非常感兴趣的事情。所以作为一个年轻女儿的父亲，我对应该为大学存多少钱很感兴趣？
should it still really be set up that way? And should schools change to follow what occupations people will actually follow? So this is something I'm actually really interested in. So having a young daughter, I'm interested in what should I save for college?
到那时大学会非常昂贵。大学会变得不同吗？我应该干脆不费心了吗？我应该鼓励她做什么？我应该如何帮助她？我认为这里有几件事你需要平衡。好吧，我想我应该把这个问题交给你来回答，抱歉。不，不。因为我读了这个问题。我们轮流来。没关系。所以我喜欢这个。我很高兴你对这个问题充满热情。所以有几件事你需要平衡。所以第一点是，当你年轻的时候，你通常不知道当你长大后想成为什么样的人，对吧？
College is going to be really expensive by the time. Is college going to be different? Should I just not bother? What should I encourage her to do? How should I help her? And I think there's a couple of things you have to balance here. Well, I guess I should have given this to you to answer, sorry. No, no. Because I read the question. We'll trade off. It's okay. So I like this. I'm glad that you're passionate about this question. So there's a couple of things you have to balance. So one is when you're young, you often don't know what you want to be when you grow up, right?
所以我真的不知道我长大后想成为什么样的人，在某种程度上。但是，你知道，你越年轻，如果你开始得太早，你就是在把人分门别类，对吧？是的。
So I really don't really know what I want to be when I grow up to some extent. But, you know, younger you are, if you start too early, you're siloing people, right? Yeah.
然后人们在意识到这不是他们想做的事情之前，就已经在某件事上走得太远了。然后就很难转换了，因为如果你转换，你就是在放弃多年的，你知道，
And then people kind of get too far into something before they realize it's not what they want to do. And then it's hard to switch because if you switch, you're giving up years of, you know,
在那件事上的经验，而别人有这些经验，你却没有。事实上，作为一个有欧洲家庭背景的人，我的大多数表亲，我的父母最初来自欧洲。我注意到他们在欧洲做得早得多。所以很早的时候，甚至早在我们这里的初中，你知道你选择一个学科，我注意到结果是，我的许多来自欧洲的表亲，他们也学习计算机科学，因为我们是一个书呆子家庭，我想这是基因里的，但……他们非常擅长数学和理论以及计算机科学，但他们并没有那种创造力，那种非常广泛的创造力，他们不知道我们知道的关于心理学的东西，所以看看所有这些通识教育，我想我在大学时就是这么叫的，他们没有我们那样的广度，你知道，所以我认为我们不早点专业化实际上是一件好事。所以还有另一个方面，就是专业化，这是一个问题，你有另一个问题，就是不同的人以不同的方式学习，对吧？所以这很多都很困难，因为这是一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，对吧？所以……公司被设置为雇佣大学毕业生，或者，你知道，从事高技能的知识型工作，比如去硅谷为一家大型公司工作，比如雅虎，你要去为雅虎工作，
experience in that thing that other people have and you won't have. And actually, so having a family from Europe, most of my cousins, my parents are originally from Europe. I noticed that they do this much earlier in Europe. So very early on, even as early as in what would be middle school over here, you know you're you pick a discipline and i noticed as a result that the um the a lot of my cousins from europe who also study computer science because we're kind of like a nerd family i guess it's in the genes but um they they have they're extremely good at like math and theory and computer you know science but they don't really have like that creative like the very broad creative like they don't know have like that creative like the very broad creative like
而……有一个 Programming Throwdown，也许我们会选一家编程公司，软件公司。所以你要去为雅虎工作，雅虎被设置为雇佣大学毕业生，对吧？对吧，你知道，即使他们已经在职场工作了很长时间，他们仍然会假设他们在某种程度上上了大学，或者有非常好的专业背景来雇佣他们。然后大学期望人们从高中毕业，他们期望他们达到一定的水平。而高中必须期望初中及以下。但在你成长的过程中，如果你要上大学，而大学是某种方式，高中就有义务帮助你为那种类型的大学做准备，所以你知道，比如人们可能通过不同的方法学习得更好，或者上网，或者玩游戏，或者看视频，但如果这对你来说不是一个选择，当你进入大学时，现在这……
they don't know the things that we know about like psychology so see all these like gen ed i think there's what it was called when i was in college they don't have the breadth that we do you know and so i think it's actually just a great thing that we don't specialize early so there is still like another aspect of it which is so you have that right it's like specializing and there's an issue you have another which is the way like different people learn different ways right and so a lot of this is hard because the it's a chicken and egg problem right so uh companies are set up to hire college graduates or you know take like a you know a highly skilled knowledge-based job like going to work in silicon valley for a large let's say yahoo you're going to go work for yahoo
变得越来越不是一个问题了，但如果你不能那样学习并获得当今社会所接受的东西，高中在某种程度上就辜负了你，对吧？因为你没有准备好进入大学并学习那种“学会如何学习”的方法，这就是你听到的，这虽然是陈词滥调，但就像，哦，你被教的不是技能，而是学会如何学习，这样当你到达你要去的地方时，你就会知道如何弄清楚该做什么。是的，所以你必须平衡那个方面，你知道，有些人可能在当前的系统中学习得非常好，有些工作必须那样做。而且，我们把大量人口教育到一定水平也很重要，比如，你知道，拥有一个良好的、受过教育的公民群体。所以这也很重要。但我的意思是，展望未来，我认为我们将看到变化，我们将看到教育方式和正在发生的事情的转变。在那之前，我们只能静观其变，因为大的变化，你知道，也是危险的，因为虽然你可能真的很喜欢那种“走出去做你自己的事而不是上大学”的想法，你知道，在这一点上，你可能会做得很好。比如，我知道有人那样做做得很好，
and um there's a programming throwdown maybe we'll pick a programming company software company so you're going to work for yahoo is set up to hire people out of college right right you know even if they've been in the workforce a long time like they'll still assume they went to college at some level or have a really good professional background to hire them. And then colleges expect people out of high schools and they expect them with a certain amount of level. And high schools have to expect middle school and on down. But as you're growing up, if you're going to go to college and college is a certain way, the high school has some obligation to help you prepare for a college that's of that type so you know things like oh people might learn better by you know um different methods or going online or playing games or watching videos but if you if that's not an option for you when you get to college now it's
嗯，有一个编程竞赛，也许我们会选一家编程公司、软件公司，所以你要去雅虎工作，雅虎的设置就是从大学招聘毕业生，对吧？你知道，即使他们已经在职场工作了很长时间，他们仍然会假设他们在某种程度上上过大学，或者有非常好的专业背景才会录用他们。然后大学期望高中毕业生达到一定的水平。高中必须期望初中及以下阶段。但在你成长的过程中，如果你打算上大学，而大学是某种特定的模式，高中就有义务帮助你为那种类型的大学做好准备，所以你知道，比如人们可能通过不同的方法、上网、玩游戏或看视频学习效果更好，但如果当你进入大学时这不是一个选择，那么现在它就
becoming less and less of that's a problem but if you can't learn that way and get what's accepted of society today the high school has failed you in some way right because you're not prepared to go into college and learn the way like learning how to learn that's what you hear it and it's society today the high school has failed you in some way right because you're not prepared to go into college and learn the way like learning how to learn that's what you hear it and it's cliche but like oh you're being taught not the skills but learning how to learn so that when you get wherever you're going you'll know like how to figure out what to do yeah and so you have to balance that that other aspect of it and you know some people may learn really good in the current system and some jobs are necessary to do that way. And it is also important that we educate a large
变得越来越不是问题了，但如果你不能以那种方式学习并获得当今社会所接受的东西，那么高中在某种程度上就辜负了你，对吧？因为你没有准备好进入大学并以那种方式学习，也就是学会如何学习，这就是你所听到的，虽然是陈词滥调，但就像是，哦，你被教导的不是技能，而是学会如何学习，这样当你到达任何地方时，你都会知道如何弄清楚该做什么。是的，所以你必须平衡那另一方面，你知道有些人可能在当前的系统中学习得非常好，有些工作也确实需要那样做。而且教育好广大
population to a certain level, like, you know, to have a good, learned citizenry. And so that's important as well. But I mean, going forward, I think we are going to see changes, we're going to see shifts and how education is done and what's going on. And until then, we kind of just have to sit tight because big changes, you know, are also dangerous because although you may really like the idea of, you know, just going out and doing your own thing instead of going to college, you know, at this point, like, you could do well. Like, I know people who have done well doing that,
人口达到一定水平，比如，你知道，拥有一个受过良好教育的公民群体，这也很重要。所以这也是很重要的。但我的意思是，展望未来，我认为我们将看到变化，我们将看到教育方式和正在发生的事情发生转变。在此之前，我们只能静观其变，因为重大的变革也伴随着危险，因为虽然你可能真的很喜欢那种不去上大学而是自己去闯的想法，你知道，在这一点上，你可能会做得很好。比如，我知道有些人这样做也做得很好，
but you can't really recommend that because it's not – we don't have a lot of statistics on how well people who do that do. That's the thing. And, and, and the thing is, is, you know, with the exception of people like Steve Jobs and things like that, but for the vast majority, um, you know, chances are when you finish with your schooling at whatever level it is, you're going to apply for jobs. Um, now if, you know, if you're this entrepreneur like Steve Jobs and you're willing to go broke broke to try and start a business, things like that, then it's sort of a little different. But for most people out there, even Steve Jobs worked at Atari for a while before he started his own business. And he was in college, in and out of college during that time.
但你不能真的推荐那样做，因为——我们没有太多关于这样做的人表现如何的统计数据。这就是问题所在。而且，而且，而且关键是，你知道，除了像史蒂夫·乔布斯那样的人，但对于绝大多数人来说，嗯，你知道，当你完成任何阶段的学业时，你很可能会去申请工作。嗯，现在如果你，你知道，如果你是像史蒂夫·乔布斯这样的企业家，并且愿意破釜沉舟去尝试创业，诸如此类，那情况就有点不同了。但对于大多数人来说，即使是史蒂夫·乔布斯在创业前也在雅达利工作过一段时间。而且在那期间，他也是断断续续地在读大学。
So a lot of businesses, they get thousands like yahoo probably gets thousands of applicants every day maybe maybe millions right who knows and so it's just not worth it for them to to to take a chance with somebody who like let's say didn't graduate high school right so it's just it's just not worth it because they know that like they would to – think of all the extra HR people, right? If they could throw out, let's say, 10% of the resumes, then that's probably going to save them, what, like $60,000, maybe $100,000. So we had this conversation. The problem is, and this is depending on the size of the company,
所以很多企业，他们每天会收到成千上万，雅虎可能每天收到成千上万甚至上百万份申请，谁知道呢，所以对他们来说，去冒险录用一个比如没有高中毕业的人是不值得的，所以这根本不划算，因为他们知道，想想所有额外的人力资源人员，对吧？如果他们能剔除掉，比如说，10%的简历，那可能能为他们节省，什么，大概6万美元，也许10万美元。所以我们进行了这次谈话。问题在于，这取决于公司规模，
but if you take a normal medium to large company, it is so hard to actually fire somebody for so many reasons. So it is really really really risky to hire the wrong person right right and so what companies do and it's to a shame they miss a lot of good we were having this conversation the other day about test anxiety right yeah so like some people just have interview anxiety and it's a shame but that company just can't there's another person where that one came from right right and somebody may look down the line and say that person went on to become the next steve jobs like you should have hired them
但如果你看一家普通的中大型公司，由于种种原因，解雇一个人真的太难了。所以雇错人真的真的真的风险很大，对吧，所以公司会怎么做，很遗憾他们错过了很多优秀的人才，我们前几天还在讨论考试焦虑，对吧，是的，有些人就是有面试焦虑，这很遗憾，但那家公司就是不能，外面还有大把的人选，对吧，而且有人可能会在未来回顾时说，那个人后来成了下一个史蒂夫·乔布斯，你们当时应该录用他的。
maybe but at the time they're probably making the right decision by not because totally you know they got to go with in some ways they're missing on the best worker because they have to take a worker that they know will fit yeah um and that's changing some with you know remote working and you know people able to do other stuff. You can set up a presence online, which you couldn't do before. Yeah, you can prove, like, here I have a portfolio of stuff I'm demonstrating. But at the same time, if you have that much initiative to not go to college and to do really well and still learn, you know, you probably don't want to go work for one of those big companies anyways. Yeah.
也许吧，但在当时他们可能做出了正确的决定，因为完全，你知道，他们必须选择，在某种程度上他们错过了最好的员工，因为他们必须选择一个他们知道能胜任的员工，是的，嗯，随着远程办公和人们能够做其他事情，这种情况正在发生一些变化。你可以建立在线形象，这是以前做不到的。是的，你可以证明，比如，我这里有一个作品集来展示我的能力。但与此同时，如果你有那么大的主动性不去上大学，并且做得非常好还能持续学习，你知道，你可能无论如何也不想去那些大公司工作。是的。
But I'm a big proponent of apprenticeship. Like, I think that would be really awesome and a good thing right which is basically instead you would go to college but college would be much more limited maybe online general education type a little bit of specific but then instead of all that money being spent you know to be taught you would go apprentice with somebody so people would offer themselves up for apprenticeship and they would be trained as apprentice mentors. Apprentice. No,
但我非常支持学徒制。比如，我认为那会非常棒，是一件好事，基本上你不用去上大学，或者大学会变得非常有限，也许是些在线通识教育，稍微学点具体的，但与其把那么多钱花在被教导上，不如去跟某人当学徒，所以人们会提供自己作为学徒，他们会被训练成学徒导师。学徒。不，
I think mentor. I don't know what the master, I think a master, maybe master. Okay. Anyways, whatever. Right.
我想是导师。我不知道什么是大师，我想是大师，也许是大师。好吧。总之，随便吧。对。
And so like you would be able to find one and like, Oh, I want to be a software engineer and you would pay him. Why? Because he's going to teach you some of the secrets. Yeah. He's going to be less efficient because he has to teach you, but you're going to work alongside him. And in some ways I think that would be better. But but in some ways if you go back and look at what apprenticeship
所以你能够找到一个，比如，我想成为一名软件工程师，然后你会付钱给他。为什么？因为他会教你一些秘诀。是的。他会因为必须教你而效率降低，但你会和他并肩工作。在某些方面我认为这会更好。但但在某些方面，如果你回头看看学徒制
was like then maybe we ought to be careful and like indentured servants and well basically you you know and uh so i read read a little bit about people becoming like uh chefs and so like you start off and like you're doing like that you're like scrubbing mushrooms all night long for like weeks then you're like you upgrade to peeling carrots for months. And then you get to dice something. And you keep getting yelled at by the chef and working horrible hours. And you do this for years in the hopes that you might get a chance to demonstrate yourself. I don't know.
是什么样子的，也许我们应该小心，比如契约仆人，嗯，基本上你，你知道，嗯，所以我读了一些关于人们成为，比如，厨师的事情，所以你开始时，比如你做的是，你就像整晚都在刷蘑菇，持续几周，然后你升级到剥胡萝卜，持续几个月。然后你才能切点东西。而且你一直被主厨吼，工作时间还很糟糕。你这样做几年，希望能有机会证明自己。我不知道。
That's better. Yeah, that's pretty rough. Okay. So there's a balance, like everything. And we need to explore options. But I think for now, I think in the short term, I don't see any big, big changes in the way companies will do hiring and stuff. And the other thing, so the email seemed to indicate specifically, like, schedule. Like, I remember, you know, when I went to high school, it was like when I was in high school.
那更好。是的，那相当艰苦。好吧。所以凡事都有平衡。我们需要探索各种选择。但我认为目前，短期内，我没看到公司在招聘等方面会有什么大的变化。还有一件事，邮件似乎特别指出了时间表。比如，我记得，你知道，我上高中的时候，就像我上高中的时候。
Walked uphill. So this is no joke. I had to get up at 4.30 in the morning to catch. So real quick anecdote, I went to this kind of special school. The way my area in Florida was set up was they had special schools for people who had special interests. So my interest was engineering, so they had an engineering school. And anyone within like
走上坡路。所以这不是开玩笑。我必须在早上4点半起床去赶车。所以简单讲个轶事，我上的是那种特殊学校。我在佛罗里达的那个地区是这样设置的，他们为有特殊兴趣的人开设了特殊学校。所以我的兴趣是工程，所以他们有一所工程学校。任何在，比如
i think like 50 miles or something could go to the school for free they would bus you and everything like if as long as you had like certain aptitudes so i went to school that was super far away the bus only picked up like six people and i had to get up at 4 30 in the morning to get there by seven right it was crazy and you know i've i don't think i've ever woken up at 4 30 since high school like ever um so it's true that like the schedule you know starting at seven is kind of you know as computer science we were kind of used to just getting up whenever starting whenever and and you know it's like and then going you know working our time it's hard right maybe i'm getting older it's self-control right like it builds character but yeah that's the big thing is i think that it's a combination of two things one is school is as
我想大概50英里以内的人都可以免费去这所学校，他们会提供校车等等，只要你有一定的天赋，所以我去了一所非常远的学校，校车只接了大概六个人，我必须在早上4点半起床才能在7点赶到，对吧，这太疯狂了，而且你知道，我从高中以后就没在4点半起过床，从来没有，嗯，所以确实，比如7点开始的时间表，你知道，作为计算机科学专业，我们习惯了随时起床，随时开始，而且，你知道，就像，然后去，你知道，完成我们的工作时间，这很难，对吧，也许我老了，这是自控力，对吧，就像它塑造性格一样，但是的，这是最重要的事情，我认为这是两件事的结合，一是学校既是
much a social like like learning platform as it is a way to teach you algebra and geometry and these things so you know the fact that you're all in it together really means something and i got a lot out of just being in a room full of people who are all doing the same thing. So I felt like that was a great thing. One thing that I'm thinking of right now is I made a calculator program, which could do the quadratic equation and things like that. I think you told us this story.
一个社交学习平台，也是一种教你代数、几何和这些东西的方式，所以你知道，你们都在一起学习确实意义重大，我从和一群都在做同样事情的人待在一个房间里学到了很多。所以我感觉那是一件很棒的事情。我现在想到的一件事是我编写了一个计算器程序，可以做二次方程之类的东西。我想你给我们讲过这个故事。
But yeah, go ahead. Oh, yeah. Real brief. And then the teacher. Maybe you just told me. I don't know. Possibly. So the teacher, she realized we were doing this.
但是的，请继续。哦，是的。非常简短。然后老师。也许你刚告诉过我。我不知道。有可能。所以老师，她意识到我们在做这个。
She realized I had given the program to everybody. And she made us all wipe our calculators before every test. And then of course I wrote, I wrote that program again. And then I wrote a program that looked like you were wiping the calculator, but you weren't. It was pretty all little, little arms race going on there, but you know, it was cool to get everyone in on it and something fun about that. And so to do that, um, everyone has to be there at the same time. And, you know, as parents now, we can start to understand, or at least you as a parent, can start to understand how hard it is to, like, work around your kid's schedule and, like, take them to school and get yourself to work and things like that.
她意识到我把程序给了所有人。她让我们在每次考试前都清空计算器。然后当然，我又写了那个程序。然后我写了一个程序，看起来像是在清空计算器，但其实并没有。那真是一场小小的军备竞赛，但你知道，让每个人都参与进来很酷，这很有趣。所以要做到这一点，嗯，每个人都必须同时在那里。而且，你知道，作为现在的父母，我们可以开始理解，或者至少你作为父母，可以开始理解围绕孩子的时间表有多难，比如，带他们去学校，让自己去上班等等。
So, you know, high school schedule, the whole school schedule, as a receiver of that schedule, it sucked. I hated getting up early and things like that. But now I can sort of understand why it is that way. And, you know, it's Brian, you know, it really sucks getting up early. But then you can go to college in, like, did he say what year he was? No. No, but in at most three years from now, you'll be in college and you can set your own schedule.
所以，你知道，高中时间表，整个学校时间表，作为那个时间表的接收者，它糟透了。我讨厌早起之类的。但现在我可以理解为什么它是那样了。而且，你知道，布莱恩，你知道，早起真的很糟糕。但你可以在，比如，他说他几年级了吗？没有。没有，但在最多三年后，你就会上大学，你可以设定自己的时间表。
Yeah, no, I mean, I feel it's like the angst when you know something better is coming. And like you can see, like we can see now, colleges will change. Like they'll change. But you're not sure quite how they're going to change. There will be some people who will take bold steps. And down the road will be, you know, praises heaped upon them as pioneers but there will be a lot of people who try crazy things and kind of fail and you'll just kind of forget about them but you know their lives might be is the what is that called i don't know there's like a
是的，不，我的意思是，我感觉就像当你预知有更好的事情即将到来时的那种焦虑。就像你可以看到，就像我们现在能看到的，大学会改变。它们会改变。但你不确定它们会如何改变。会有一些人采取大胆的步骤。在未来，你知道，赞美会像先驱一样堆积在他们身上，但也会有很多人尝试疯狂的事情然后失败，你只会忘记他们，但你知道他们的生活可能是，那叫什么，我不知道，有种
name for it but basically like the personal risk to you is like very high so like if a huge amount of people try crazy things some people will succeed and then you have you know survivorship bias like those are the people you remember but there'll be a whole bunch of people who fall by the wayside as kind of crazies totally you know so there's a risk but yeah we feel yeah i remember that yeah it was rough it does get better all right so here we go you want to read this one uh sure this is from joshua brown uh and unfortunately josh had to go so he's going to be watching this later. What's the word called? Post-talk? Or post-talk? He's going to be watching
名字，但基本上就像你个人的风险非常高，所以如果大量的人尝试疯狂的事情，有些人会成功，然后你就有，你知道，幸存者偏差，那些是你记住的人，但会有很多人在路边倒下，被视为疯子，完全，你知道，所以有风险，但是的，我们感觉，是的，我记得那个，是的，那很艰难，它确实会变好。好吧，我们开始吧，你想读这一条吗？嗯，当然，这是来自约书亚·布朗的，不幸的是，乔什不得不走了，所以他稍后会看这个。那个词叫什么？事后？还是事后？他稍后会看
this later. But his question is, I'm just learning programming using your recommended Learn Python the hard way. My goal is to integrate Circos into Solus OS as a file manager. What sort of language should I be learning
这个。但他的问题是，我正在使用你们推荐的《笨办法学Python》学习编程。我的目标是将Circos集成到Solus OS中作为文件管理器。我应该学习什么样的语言
after I master Python to accomplish this? So I actually looked this up. Oh, okay, good. I was about to say. No worries. So yeah, I found this question kind of interesting because I didn't know what either of those two things were. So Solus OS is a Linux distro forked from Debian.
在我掌握Python之后来完成这个？所以我确实查了一下。哦，好的，很好。我正要说。不用担心。所以是的，我发现这个问题很有趣，因为我不知道那两样东西是什么。所以Solus OS是一个从Debian派生出来的Linux发行版。
Okay. So effectively Debian. And Circos is a pretty cool visualization library written in Perl where you give it some XML in a certain format. It digests the XML and produces some really beautiful pictures. Yeah, I'm on the page now.
好的。所以实际上就是Debian。而Circos是一个非常酷的可视化库，用Perl编写，你给它提供特定格式的XML。它消化XML并产生一些非常漂亮的图片。是的，我现在就在那个页面上。
This is cool. Yeah, so the short answer, and then we can always jump into more detail, but basically the Circos accepts XML, and so you can use any programming language you want. So there's XML writers for just about any language. Don't try and write your own XML, like write the open tag, write the greater than sign. Don't do that. There's XML writers.
这很酷。是的，所以简短的回答，我们可以随时深入细节，但基本上Circos接受XML，所以你可以使用任何你想要的编程语言。所以几乎任何语言都有XML编写器。不要尝试自己写XML，比如写开始标签，写大于号。不要那样做。有XML编写器。
If you're using Python, which you said that you're studying, you can totally use Python. There's an XML library you can import. And it's pretty awesome. It lets you write XML. I've used it before. It's great. You can write your XML,
如果你正在使用Python，也就是你说你正在学习的，你完全可以使用Python。有一个你可以导入的XML库。它非常棒。它让你编写XML。我以前用过它。它很棒。你可以编写你的XML，
and then the Circos program can digest it and produce those awesome graphs. Yeah, I mean, I think part of, like like learning programming, and this is something I struggle with, but it's like struggling to do things in the programming, like the thing you know. So everything's a nail when all you have is a hammer. Yeah, right. Right. And part of what we talk about programming through now is learning like other languages,
然后Circos程序可以消化它并产生那些很棒的图表。是的，我的意思是，我认为部分，就像学习编程，这是我挣扎的事情，但就像在编程中挣扎着做事情，就像你知道的那样。所以当你只有一把锤子时，一切看起来都像钉子。是的，对。对。而我们现在谈论编程的一部分是学习其他语言，
but go for it. Like try to, when you're learning a language, part of it is going for, if you only know one language, like trying to solve something before you're learning a language, part of it is going for, if you only know one language, like trying to solve something before you realize like, oh, this is bad at this. And then you know what to go look for the replacement. Like what characteristics of the replacement should be. And if you know multiple languages,
但去尝试吧。就像尝试，当你学习一门语言时，部分原因是，如果你只知道一门语言，比如在学习一门语言之前尝试解决某事，部分原因是，如果你只知道一门语言，比如在意识到“哦，这在这一点上很糟糕”之前尝试解决某事。然后你就知道去寻找什么替代品了。替代品应该具备什么特征。如果你知道多种语言，
you can't learn what the pros and cons of that language are until you try to do something and kind of realize like, oh, it doesn't really work for this. Oh, it's really good at this, but really bad at this. Right? And so, you know, I think that's like part of like the learning is like you kind of just have to go for it and see how far like see where you'll get stuck because until like i haven't done this before like i've never you know integrated these two things together it sounds kind of cool like when i look at that website it looks it looks really nice yeah josh real quick talking in
你无法学习该语言的优缺点，直到你尝试做某事并意识到“哦，它在这一点上真的不行。哦，它在这一点上真的很擅长，但在那一点上真的很糟糕。”对吧？所以，你知道，我认为这就是学习的一部分，就像你只需要去尝试，看看你会走多远，看看你会卡在哪里，因为直到，比如我以前没做过这个，我从来没有，你知道，把这两样东西集成在一起，这听起来很酷，当我查看那个网站时，它看起来真的很不错。是的，乔什，简单说一下，
if you do this let us know we want to see. And if it works on Ubuntu, even better. So, yeah, I mean, like, I think part of it is, like, nobody's done it before, so you kind of got to try something and then ask for help, right? And then be like, oh, like, how do I do this thing? Like, oh, Python's not good for that? Like, oh, okay. And as you grow as a programmer, part of that is, like, doing that sooner.
如果你做了这个，让我们知道，我们想看看。如果它能在Ubuntu上运行，那就更好了。所以，是的，我的意思是，我认为部分原因是，没有人以前做过，所以你必须尝试一些东西，然后寻求帮助，对吧？然后说，哦，比如，我该怎么做这件事？比如，哦，Python不擅长那个？比如，哦，好的。随着你作为程序员的成长，部分原因是，更早地做到这一点。
Right? So, like, you know, you've talked about this with some of the machine learning algorithms, especially AI stuff, about pruning that tree. When you're playing chess, understanding this path of plays goes nowhere good. I don't need to go process the whole thing. Part of it is learning as you program. That's heuristics. Like, oh, hmm, this language looks like it supports regular expressions really well.
对吧？所以，你知道，你已经和一些机器学习算法谈过这个，特别是AI方面，关于修剪那棵树。当你下棋时，理解这条路径走不通。我不需要去处理整个事情。部分原因是边编程边学习。那是启发式方法。比如，哦，嗯，这门语言看起来对正则表达式支持得很好。
I don't care. I'm not going to use regular expressions you know or like oh this this thing doesn't isn't performant it doesn't run really fast but that's okay because i'm doing something only once like i only need to do this thing once so yeah that's not a huge thing for me yeah totally totally yeah but that's a good question though yeah and joshua brown uh was from los angeles he said okay pretty cool getting questions from around. Yeah, but that's a good question, though. Yeah, great question. And Joshua Brown was from Los Angeles, he said. Ah, okay, cool. Pretty cool getting questions from around the world. Cool, and that looked like open source projects then, right? Yeah, both of those were. A great way to get involved.
我不在乎。我不会使用正则表达式，你知道，或者比如，哦，这个东西性能不好，它运行得不快，但这没关系，因为我只做一次，我只需要做一次这件事，所以是的，这对我不重要。是的，完全，完全，是的，但这是一个好问题。是的，约书亚·布朗来自洛杉矶，他说，好的，很酷，能收到来自世界各地的提问。是的，但这是一个好问题。是的，好问题。约书亚·布朗来自洛杉矶，他说。啊，好的，很酷。能收到来自世界各地的提问真的很酷。酷，那看起来像是开源项目，对吧？是的，两者都是。参与其中的好方法。
It's really intimidating at first to get involved in open source. It's always overwhelming and you kind of want to quit, but you just kind of have to stick in there for a while, try it, and eventually you'll start to make at least a little progress and then yeah the cool thing that josh is doing is that he already has something in mind that he wants to use this library for so you know if it turns out that oh uh the library doesn't work when i give it you know file names because file names have colons in them and the library crashes on colons well he, he's going to be really compelled to go into the open source library, fix the colon problem, submit a patch to GitHub where this is located,
起初参与开源真的很吓人。它总是让人不知所措，你有点想放弃，但你只需要坚持一段时间，尝试一下，最终你会开始取得至少一点进展，然后是的，乔什正在做的很酷的事情是，他已经有了他想用这个库做的事情，所以你知道，如果结果是，哦，当我给它文件名时，库无法工作，因为文件名中有冒号，而库在冒号上崩溃了，好吧，他会非常有动力去进入开源库，修复冒号问题，向GitHub提交补丁，
and get them to fix it. And then you have a great feeling afterwards. It's like, I made a contribution that made this library even better. And so it's pretty awesome. It's a great way to sort of get started. Yeah, so as a slight segue, this is actually really interesting. So going from one company I was working at in Florida, which didn't do that much with open source stuff really,
让他们修复它。然后你之后会有一种很棒的感觉。就像，我做出了一个贡献，让这个库变得更好了。所以这非常棒。这是一个很好的入门方式。是的，作为一个小小的转折，这实际上非常有趣。所以从我在佛罗里达工作的一家公司，它在开源方面做得不多，
and didn't encourage people to kind of modify the source and change something to back to a company where it's actually been slightly a struggle for me. I've been criticized a couple times and also find other people doing it just blowing my mind where it's like oh the library doesn't support this this thing doesn't work recompile it change it submit it back you know like fix it like where are you like just changing what you do or working around it just
也不鼓励人们修改源代码并改变某些东西，回到一家公司，这对我来说实际上有点挣扎。我被批评了几次，也发现其他人这样做让我大吃一惊，就像“哦，这个库不支持这个，这个东西不能用，重新编译它，改变它，提交回去，你知道，就像修复它，就像你在哪里，只是改变你所做的或者绕过它，只是
fix it and it's like what yeah exactly are you crazy like oh and if you don't fix it at least let them know like you should tell that open source project hey i would really love to use it this way and like you know you guys should fix this yeah um yeah that just yeah yeah it's pretty wild that's a good thing about working i guess out here in silicon valley is like people are more open to those kinds of things yeah totally i mean i you know silicon valley has this thing where you know there's many startups like all these companies like twitter was a startup with like who knows three four people and then it grew right all of these companies started off very small and so they're sort of indebted to these open source projects otherwise you know they a small
修复它”，就像“什么，是的，你疯了吗？哦，如果你不修复它，至少让他们知道，你应该告诉那个开源项目，嘿，我真的很想这样使用它，你们应该修复这个问题。”是的，嗯，是的，那真的，是的，这很疯狂，我认为在硅谷工作的好处是人们对这类事情更开放。是的，完全，我的意思是，你知道，硅谷有这样一种情况，有很多初创公司，比如所有这些公司，比如Twitter曾经是一家初创公司，只有谁知道，三四个人，然后它成长了，对吧？所有这些公司起步时都很小，所以他们有点欠这些开源项目的债，否则，你知道，一个小
team wouldn't have been able to start something that investors could appreciate so because of this indebtedness there's like this philosophy in silicon valley that you give back now you keep a healthy ecosystem so that the next startup can get going, right? And it's probably like that in other places besides Silicon Valley. Oh, yeah, totally. That's just, you know, I can't speak to other places because I don't know. Yep, yep. So do you want to read this one?
团队将无法启动投资者能够欣赏的东西，所以因为这种负债，硅谷有一种哲学，你现在回馈，你保持一个健康的生态系统，以便下一家初创公司可以开始，对吧？在硅谷以外的其他地方可能也是这样。哦，是的，完全。那只是，你知道，我不能代表其他地方，因为我不知道。是的，是的。所以你想读这一条吗？
Sure. All right. So, hey, guys, love the show. Okay. Was this you again? You wrote all these questions. So this is Mike from Virginia. All right.
当然。好吧。所以，嘿，伙计们，喜欢这个节目。好的。这又是你吗？你写了所有这些问题。所以这是来自弗吉尼亚州的迈克。好吧。
So, hey, guys, love the show. Your discussion about the automated paper scanning to detect cheaters reminded me of one of my friends that is a teacher for an online school. She told me that they were looking to expel some of the students for plagiarism. They suspect the students are submitting the bare minimum to remain enrolled so they can collect the student loan money. Unfortunately, the teachers have to waste time dealing with these creeps instead of the actual students get less attention girl yeah i've heard of this over and over again from teacher friends
所以，嘿，伙计们，喜欢这个节目。你们关于自动论文扫描以检测作弊者的讨论让我想起了我的一位朋友，她是在线学校的老师。她告诉我，他们正在考虑开除一些抄袭的学生。他们怀疑学生提交的是最低限度的作业以保持注册状态，这样他们就可以领取学生贷款。不幸的是，老师们不得不浪费时间处理这些混蛋，而不是实际的学生得到更少的关注。女孩，是的，我从老师朋友那里一次又一次地听说过这个
and stuff really i've never heard of yeah basically like it's really hard to expel students and you spend way more time than you can really merit and so like even people who are doing deliberately bad stuff or cheating or whatever like it's almost not worth your so let it go this is sort of digressions i'll keep it short but the same is true with renters so i have a friend who's renting his house um to someone else because he moved and um the person just stopped paying their bill like stop paying their rent and it turns out that it takes like on average something like over a year to evict somebody who's not paying their rent it's just absolutely insane now like if they're if they're doing other things like if they're drinking or something then like that can expedite
之类的，真的，我从来没听说过。是的，基本上，开除学生真的很难，你花费的时间远超其价值，所以即使是那些故意做坏事或作弊的人，或者其他什么，几乎不值得你，所以放手吧。这有点离题，我会简短点，但租房者也是如此，所以我有一个朋友把他的房子租给别人，因为他搬走了，嗯，那个人只是停止支付账单，停止支付租金，结果发现平均需要一年多的时间才能驱逐一个不付房租的人，这简直太疯狂了，现在，如果他们做其他事情，比如如果他们喝酒之类的，那么这可以加快
it but if they especially if they have a lawyer or if they know the system pretty well it can take over 12 months to evict somebody who hasn't it's's just insane. Yeah, it's crazy. All right, so there's a question. Do you know of any free open source methods to sync mobile data between mobile devices, more than one, and a remote server? He's using Air Mobile App and Microsoft SQL on the server, but he's open to other options. Seems like everything requires big time customization
它，但如果他们，特别是如果他们有律师，或者如果他们很了解系统，驱逐一个没有付钱的人可能需要超过12个月，这简直太疯狂了。是的，这很疯狂。好吧，所以有一个问题。你知道任何免费的开源方法来同步移动设备（不止一个）和远程服务器之间的移动数据吗？他正在使用Air移动应用程序和服务器上的Microsoft SQL，但他对其他选择持开放态度。看起来一切都需要大量定制
to do conflict checking. So it sounds like what he's trying to do here, I would assume, is for an app he's developing. Right. So trying to have a remote server and synchronize. So I've not really done this before. So let's talk about files first. If you want to do files, there's a number of options. There's Dropbox, SugarSync, these kind of things.
来进行冲突检查。所以听起来他在这里试图做的是为他正在开发的应用程序。对。所以试图拥有一个远程服务器并进行同步。所以我以前没真正做过这个。所以我们先谈谈文件。如果你想处理文件，有很多选择。有Dropbox，SugarSync，这些东西。
And those are pretty awesome. You can actually put a file in your Dropbox and it doesn't exactly just show up magically in your phone, which I wish it did. It's actually a big complaint to have with Dropbox. You actually have to go in your phone and say, hey, sync these files. So if you add a new file, you have to,
那些非常棒。你实际上可以把一个文件放在你的Dropbox里，它不会完全神奇地出现在你的手机里，我希望它能。这实际上是Dropbox的一个大抱怨。你实际上必须进入你的手机并说，嘿，同步这些文件。所以如果你添加一个新文件，你必须，
whoop, lights just went out. Okay, they're back. So you have to actually like sync those files but once you've checked the box for the for a file then any changes you make on your phone like immediately go to the to the computer and so this this works really well for a lot of like if you want to make make notes to yourself things like that with respect to actual data this is kind of tricky, right? So the way most apps work is the phone might keep some local cached copy, but then it frequently hits the server, right?
哇，灯刚灭了。好的，它们又亮了。所以你必须实际上同步这些文件，但一旦你为文件勾选了复选框，那么你在手机上做的任何更改都会立即传送到计算机，所以这对于很多，比如如果你想给自己做笔记之类的，效果很好。关于实际数据，这有点棘手，对吧？所以大多数应用程序的工作方式是手机可能会保留一些本地缓存副本，但随后它会频繁地访问服务器，对吧？
And so you might have some server that has one database, and then as the phone needs different pieces of the database, it can grab those, and the phone needs to make updates. That's how most apps work. In your case, it sounds like you want to keep the entire database on your phone and on the server and keep the transactions in sync between the two. That's going to be pretty tricky.
所以你可能有一个拥有一个数据库的服务器，然后当手机需要数据库的不同部分时，它可以获取这些部分，并且手机需要进行更新。这就是大多数应用程序的工作方式。在你的情况下，听起来你想在手机和服务器上保留整个数据库，并保持两者之间的事务同步。那会非常棘手。
Yeah, I also don't know of a. OK, so Air. That's Adobe Air. Yeah, I don't, I don't, I don't, I also don't know of, uh, um. Okay, so Air. Oh, that's Adobe Air. That's right, that's right. Yeah, Adobe. Okay. So I can't really think of anything off the top of my head.
是的，我也不知道一个。好的，所以Air。那是Adobe Air。是的，我不知道，我不知道，我也不知道，嗯，嗯。好的，所以Air。哦，那是Adobe Air。没错，没错。是的，Adobe。好的。所以我真的想不出什么。
One thing you could do is you could have, like, a handshaking, like a negotiation thing. So basically, let's say, let's say you make the assumption that if there's a conflict, the server wins. So if you can work under that assumption, then you can have the phone and the server send messages to each other using Thrift or whatever. Maybe even Air has an RPC, like a remote procedure call framework. And so the phone would send a message to the server saying,
你可以做的一件事是，你可以有一个，比如，握手，比如协商的事情。所以基本上，假设，假设你做出这样的假设，如果发生冲突，服务器获胜。所以如果你能在那个假设下工作，那么你可以让手机和服务器使用Thrift或任何东西互相发送消息。也许Air甚至有一个RPC，比如远程过程调用框架。所以手机会向服务器发送一条消息说，
hey, change this record. Update this. Like a new student has a test. Here's the student and test an essay or something, right? And the server can also say, hey, here's a student and essay. If you get a conflict, like the same student gets created with two different essays at the same time, you just let the server win.
嘿，更改此记录。更新这个。比如一个新学生有一次考试。这是学生和考试和论文之类的，对吧？服务器也可以说，嘿，这是一个学生和论文。如果你遇到冲突，比如同一个学生同时被创建了两个不同的论文，你只需让服务器获胜。
So the phone would just take the server's answer. And if the server gets a conflict, it would just throw out the phone's answer. You could probably code something like that up. DAN GALPIN- So it's a little hard, I guess, the details are a little loose. But another thing which I've used before is Cheesy. And people don't like it.
所以手机只会接受服务器的答案。如果服务器遇到冲突，它只会丢弃手机的答案。你可能可以编写类似的东西。DAN GALPIN- 所以我想这有点难，细节有点松散。但我以前用过的另一件事是Cheesy。人们不喜欢它。
So if you have one account, one person should be editing the data at a time. And so if that's the case, you can just have a method for basically determining if somebody's currently accessing or modifying the data. And other people have to be read-only. Right, that makes sense. So essentially, the server is only a server.
所以如果你有一个帐户，一个人应该一次编辑数据。如果是这种情况，你可以只用一种方法来确定是否有人当前正在访问或修改数据。其他人必须是只读的。对，这有道理。所以本质上，服务器只是一个服务器。
Everything else has to become a client of some sort, even if it's on that computer. And when one is connected until it either logs out or has some sort of timeoutout everybody else can only be in read mode yeah makes sense and that you know that also will prevent it's a little cheesier and you know people might not like it but it is simple and straightforward the other thing would be for this is like general advice i guess when when you come across problems like this is you know really just working on the google for a while and like trying to like search out like other people have
其他一切都必须成为某种客户端，即使它在那台计算机上。当一个人连接时，直到它注销或有某种超时，其他所有人都只能处于读取模式。是的，有道理，而且你知道，那也会防止，它有点俗气，你知道人们可能不喜欢它，但它简单直接。另一件事是，这就像一般建议，我想，当你遇到这样的问题时，你知道，真的只是在谷歌上工作一段时间，并尝试搜索，比如其他人有
had similar problem try ways of rephrasing it i don't like i find maybe this is not true for our listeners but i find like people i know like in day-to-day life like just aren't good at so i say googling but i just mean searching like being whatever yahoo it doesn't matter what you use but like understanding like how to try permutation state it different ways because you don't know like part of the hard part is finding out what the word is that most people are using because it might not be the same word you're using to describe the problem um and so again forums can be a help there because other people can help you with that if they're in the the domain but also just trying a little longer at searching and trying to find somebody else who
遇到过类似的问题，尝试重新表述它的方法，我不喜欢，我发现，也许这对我们的听众来说不是真的，但我发现，我认识的人，在日常生活中，就是不擅长，所以我说谷歌搜索，但我只是指搜索，无论是什么，雅虎，你用什么并不重要，但就像理解如何尝试排列组合，以不同的方式陈述它，因为你不知道，部分困难在于找出大多数人正在使用的词，因为它可能不是你用来描述问题的同一个词，嗯，所以论坛在那里可以提供帮助，因为其他人可以在他们处于该领域时帮助你，但也只是在搜索上多花一点时间，并尝试找到其他人谁
may have encountered that problem yeah and the other thing is keep it simple right so in this case you know maybe where he's going with this is he wants to have all the students' tests on all the phones so that they can scan, so that they don't have to hit the server every time they want to check if someone's cheating. But that might be a nice optimization, but that might not be necessary.
可能遇到过那个问题。是的，另一件事是保持简单，对吧？所以在这个案例中，你知道，也许他要去的地方是他想把所有学生的考试都放在所有手机上，这样他们就可以扫描，这样他们就不必每次想检查某人是否作弊时都访问服务器。但这可能是一个很好的优化，但这可能不是必要的。
Maybe the server could check for cheating like from every phone, you know. If you have like a thousand users, then the server can check like a thousand times and it could even have a delay. It could say, hey, I'm checking 10 other people right now. Like yours is in the queue or something like that. And that might be way easier than making some kind of crazy synchronization, you know.
也许服务器可以从每部手机检查作弊，你知道。如果你有一千个用户，那么服务器可以检查一千次，它甚至可以有延迟。它可以说，嘿，我现在正在检查其他10个人。比如你的在队列中之类的。那可能比制作某种疯狂的同步要容易得多，你知道。
So keep it simple. Try and keep everything on the server if at all possible. And if you can't do that, yeah, then you could do some kind of hands synchronization. So keep it simple. Try and keep everything on the server, if at all possible. And if you can't do that, then you could do some kind of handshaking. CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- All right. So we're running kind of long on time already. We're at an hour and 10 minutes. So we'll do one or two more.
所以保持简单。如果可能的话，尽量把所有东西都放在服务器上。如果你做不到，是的，那么你可以做某种握手同步。所以保持简单。如果可能的话，尽量把所有东西都放在服务器上。如果你做不到，那么你可以做某种握手。CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- 好吧。所以我们的时间已经很长了。我们已经一个小时10分钟了。所以我们再做一两个。
CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- Yeah, let's see. So we can do two more. CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- All right. CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- So we have Corey Reese. Corey from Texas. And his question is, what programming language would you recommend for a beginner? Yeah, so I mean, we've talked about this a little bit on past shows. It kind of depends on what you want to do. But I like Python for beginners.
CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- 是的，让我们看看。所以我们可以再做两个。CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- 好吧。CHRIS BROADFOOTEN- 所以我们有Corey Reese。来自德克萨斯的Corey。他的问题是，你会推荐初学者学习什么编程语言？是的，我的意思是，我们在过去的节目中谈论过一点。这取决于你想做什么。但我喜欢Python作为初学者。
Me too. I was going to say Python. But also, I mean. We didn't rehearse that. No, no, no. But I mean, actually Erlang. Yeah, Erlang's good. No, no, no, I'm just kidding.
我也是。我正要说Python。但也，我的意思是。我们没有排练过。不，不，不。但我的意思是，实际上Erlang。是的，Erlang很好。不，不，不，我只是开玩笑。
Not so much those. I mean, you can, I guess. If you started with that, you'd be like a reaper programmer. Yeah, you'd be really good at stuff that most people aren't. So I mean, I really think Python is a good blend between easy to use, but also, and the batteries included we've talked about before in that episode, and also being useful for real world things.
不是那些。我的意思是，你可以，我想。如果你从那个开始，你会像一个收割者程序员。是的，你会非常擅长大多数人都不擅长的事情。所以我的意思是，我真的认为Python是易于使用，但也是，我们之前在那一集中谈论过的电池包含，以及对现实世界有用的东西之间的一个很好的融合。
If you want to jump straight in, Java or C++. That's what still most of the world's software houses are using. And so learning those from early, it's never a bad thing. But it's not as much reward up front.
如果你想直接跳进去，Java或C++。那是世界上大多数软件公司仍然在使用的。所以从早期学习这些，从来都不是坏事。但前期回报没那么高。
You don't get that immediate satisfaction the same way. Yeah. But you know, I'm also inclined to say JavaScript. Really? That's interesting. Why JavaScript? So, I mean, think about like all the, if you're, if you're going for like, if you're the kind of person who needs victories, like what better way, right?
你不会以同样的方式获得那种即时的满足感。是的。但你知道，我也倾向于说JavaScript。真的吗？这很有趣。为什么是JavaScript？所以，我的意思是，想想，比如所有，如果你正在，如果你正在寻找，比如，如果你是那种需要胜利的人，还有什么更好的方式，对吧？
That's true. You know, so like even if you write client server now with like Node. way, right? That's true. So, like, even if you write client server now with, like, Node.js, right? This is actually on a task of mine probably longer standing than it should have been. So I don't know JavaScript that well. I haven't really done more than just very simple stuff. But, like, all the stuff I read, I have a task of mine to learn it and to actually implement client server stuff completely in JavaScript. With, like, Node.js and a JavaScript front end and web page development.
那是真的。你知道，所以即使你现在用Node.js写客户端服务器，对吧？这实际上是我的一项任务，可能比它应该存在的时间更长。所以我不太了解JavaScript。我除了非常简单的东西之外没做过什么。但，比如，我读到的所有东西，我有一个学习它的任务，并真正用JavaScript完全实现客户端服务器的东西。用，比如，Node.js和JavaScript前端以及网页开发。
That is just so, like, I mean. You could make good, earn a living at just doing JavaScript programming. Yeah, totally. And then also, there's a lot of good tutorials out there. Because a lot of people who aren't expert programmers, that's the first thing they learn because that's what they need. So there's a lot of good resources out there. And you can do more and more than you ever could before with it. Yeah, it makes sense. And plus, you don't have to deal with deploying.
那真是太，我的意思是。你可以通过只做JavaScript编程来赚取生活。是的，完全。而且，还有很多好的教程。因为很多不是专家程序员的人，那是他们学习的第一件事，因为那是他们需要的。所以有很多好的资源。而且你可以用它做比以前更多的事情。是的，这有道理。而且，你不必处理部署。
Like, if you make some Java app, you have to, like, have people download it. And then half the people, they don't have Java installed. You have to deal with that. If you're writing something in JavaScript, you just make a website. And you're like, hey, everybody, check out my website. And it just works, you know. So as far as, like, going back to what we were saying earlier about getting feedback and being part of a community and things like that. It's way easier to say go on some forum and say
比如，如果你制作了一些Java应用程序，你必须，比如，让人下载它。然后一半的人，他们没有安装Java。你必须处理这个问题。如果你用JavaScript写东西，你只需制作一个网站。然后你说，嘿，大家，看看我的网站。它就工作了，你知道。所以就，比如，回到我们之前说的关于获得反馈和成为社区的一部分之类的事情。去某个论坛说
everyone go to this website than it is to say... Forget that. Email your mom or dad or your brother or sister or your cousin or your aunt and like, hey, what do you think about this? Yep. It's much harder to be like download this Java and run this. Download this 100 meg jar file that I have
每个人都去这个网站，比说……忘了那个。给你的妈妈或爸爸或你的兄弟或姐妹或你的表亲或你的阿姨发电子邮件，比如，嘿，你觉得这个怎么样？是的。要像下载这个Java并运行它那样做要难得多。下载这个我有的100兆jar文件
and then double click on it. Yeah, yeah. So JavaScript's actually an I have, and then double-click on it. Yeah, yeah. So JavaScript's actually an amazing choice. I didn't even think about it. Okay, so that's a non-personal recommendation. But as far as everything I read, I mean, I wouldn't feel too bad about somebody taking that advice. Yeah, totally.
然后双击它。是的，是的。所以JavaScript实际上是一个惊人的选择。我甚至没想过。好的，所以这是一个非个人的建议。但就我读到的所有内容而言，我的意思是，我不会因为有人采纳那个建议而感到太糟糕。是的，完全。
So one last question. This is from Joey Andres. And I'm using his email address to infer his location. His email address says he's from Alberta, Canada. All right. So we'll assume that that's true. His question is, he's a first-year undergrad majoring in computer science. He's starting to realize the importance of number theory and invariance. what path should he take to
所以最后一个问题。这是来自Joey Andres。我正在使用他的电子邮件地址来推断他的位置。他的电子邮件地址说他来自加拿大阿尔伯塔省。好吧。所以我们假设那是真的。他的问题是，他是一名计算机科学专业的大一本科生。他开始意识到数论和不变性的重要性。他应该走什么路径来
sort of understand more about like the math behind computer science? So how can you get into sort of the theoretical parts of it? I think this is your, this is like the bowling ball is going straight down your lane. Yeah, this is awful. Okay. So I'll totally take this. Great question, Joey. So yeah, the mathematics of computer science is super, super interesting.
稍微多了解一点计算机科学背后的数学？所以你怎么能进入它的理论部分？我认为这是你的，这就像保龄球正顺着你的车道滚下去。是的，这太糟糕了。好的。所以我完全接受这个。好问题，Joey。所以是的，计算机科学的数学超级超级有趣。
You know, number theory, of course, incredibly important. A lot of interesting things there. I would think, like, one of the best ways to get into this kind of thing is to get into complexity analysis. Because that's something you're going to have to do a lot of anyways. Interesting. And that is something that's something you're going to have to do a lot of anyways and that is something it's sort of it's very intuitive like the way it starts is imagine if you have like a list of you know the way they do it typically is with sorting right so you have a list of numbers
你知道，数论当然非常重要。里面有很多有趣的东西。我认为，进入这类领域最好的方法之一就是从复杂度分析入手。因为无论如何，你都要做很多这方面的工作。很有趣。而且这是你无论如何都要做很多的事情，它非常直观，比如它的入门方式是，想象如果你有一个列表，你知道他们通常的做法是排序，对吧？所以你有一个数字列表
and then they show you this thing called bubble sort where you have two for loops and then inside the two for loops you do some swapping right writers there's some there's some conditional swapping there and when you're done the list is sorted and you can see this takes n squared time and you can actually see it in the for loops like you have the end and then inside the for loop you have another you have another end so in square um then they get into like n log n and things like that and then they show how things like a like a heap are order one on amortized order one even though there are cases where you know heap
然后他们会向你展示一种叫做冒泡排序的东西，你有两个for循环，然后在两个for循环内部你做一些交换，对吧，有一些条件交换，当你完成后，列表就排好序了，你可以看到这需要n平方的时间，你实际上可以在for循环中看到它，就像你有一个n，然后在for循环内部你又有另一个n，所以是n平方。嗯，然后他们会深入到像n log n之类的内容，然后他们会展示像堆（heap）这样的东西是如何在摊销后达到O(1)的，尽管在某些情况下，你知道堆
insertion and deletion actually heap retrieval is always order one anyways there's some algorithms like heap insertion say which can be order log n but uh but if you do it in a certain way amortized, which means kind of like on average it's order one so anyways, these complexity analysis is a good way to get started and it's really useful as an engineer when you're designing new algorithms
插入和删除，实际上堆检索总是O(1)。总之，有一些算法，比如堆插入，可能是O(log n)，但如果你以某种方式进行摊销，这意味着平均来说它是O(1)。所以无论如何，这些复杂度分析是一个很好的入门方式，作为工程师，在设计新算法时它非常有用
to say if I design it this way it can be way faster we're talking, instead of taking years it takes three minutes some of the even more like deeply theoretical things about like you know complexity not complexity but like information like how much information is there like Kalma Gaurav complexity of algorithms and data and
比如，如果我这样设计，它可能会快得多。我们谈论的是，原本需要几年的时间，现在只需要三分钟。甚至还有一些更深奥的理论，比如复杂度，不是复杂度，而是信息，比如有多少信息，像算法和数据的柯尔莫哥洛夫复杂度（Kolmogorov complexity）以及
things like that that that stuff is super interesting but that could be like a higher barrier of entry, you know? So by starting with complexity analysis, it's something like sort of easy to grasp. Then you can sort of jump into some of the other things. Yeah, so I mean I guess there's kind of two ways to view that question. I think that's probably like the way you're viewing. But the other thing that, I mean, you run into a lot in computers depending on what you do, is even stuff that's not directly computer science but is related related so like like discrete math or whatever like how floating point numbers work so that can get interesting but even less obvious things like prime numbers
诸如此类的事情，那些东西超级有趣，但入门门槛可能更高，你知道吗？所以从复杂度分析开始，它比较容易掌握。然后你可以跳到其他一些事情上。是的，我的意思是，我想看待这个问题有两种方式。我认为这可能就是你看待它的方式。但另一件事是，我的意思是，你在计算机领域经常会遇到，取决于你做什么，即使是那些不直接属于计算机科学但相关的东西，比如离散数学之类的，或者浮点数是如何工作的，这可能会变得很有趣，甚至是一些不那么明显的东西，比如素数
it's like right like calculating prime numbers or you know uh geometric algorithms right like kind of doing stuff that's like a convex hole right like these kind of things involve math and if you don't know what they mean you can can look them up. And so, you know, those things you do encounter in programming fairly frequently and you hear them discussed. So those are, I guess, kind of related to like number theory type stuff or whatever. And those are interesting to me. I never got very deep into them, but kind of understanding them because a lot of stuff like cryptography you come across has a lot to do with, with prime numbers and that kind of stuff. And then just getting more of an understanding of that kind of level of math can be really useful.
就像计算素数，或者几何算法，比如做一些像凸包（convex hull）之类的事情，这些事情涉及数学，如果你不知道它们是什么意思，你可以查一下。所以，你知道，这些东西你在编程中确实会经常遇到，而且你会听到人们讨论它们。所以我想，这些与数论之类的内容有关。这些对我来说很有趣。我从来没有深入研究过它们，但理解它们很有用，因为很多像密码学这样的东西，你接触到的很多都与素数之类的内容有关。因此，对那种层面的数学有更多的了解真的很有用。
And I find for that, I would recommend something like Project Euler, depending on how you say it. You can search it, Project E-U-L-E-R, and they have various programming challenges, problems. And a lot of those, if I recall correctly, will involve to understand things like you know how to find a prime number or they'll actually give you kind of like a little bit of like here's the certain kinds of numbers we're looking for you should calculate these you know these are highly related to like ACM programming competitions if you see those or something called top
我发现对于这一点，我会推荐像Project Euler这样的东西，取决于你怎么读它。你可以搜索它，Project E-U-L-E-R，他们有各种编程挑战和问题。如果我没记错的话，其中很多都会涉及理解诸如如何找到素数之类的知识，或者他们实际上会给你一点提示，比如“这是我们要寻找的特定数字，你应该计算这些”，你知道，这些与ACM编程竞赛高度相关，如果你看到那些，或者叫Top
coder you can go on there and those very deeply a top coder for instance or even ACM will combine what Jason's talking about with what I'm talking about so you'll need to know on the one hand like how our prime number is calculated and on the other hand the default algorithm for doing that unless the problem gives you some cheat like way to shortcut it like what would that complexity be yeah and could I do it in enough time Or do I need to look for that shortcut, you know, and find out what it is? Is that the trick to solving the problem? And those methods are often they'll have solutions for you. So you can see what you should have done. And then you can learn from that. Yeah, another, just to recommend some reading material on this is
Coder，你可以去那里，那些非常深入。例如Top Coder，甚至ACM，会将Jason谈论的内容与我谈论的内容结合起来。所以你需要一方面知道素数是如何计算的，另一方面知道执行该操作的默认算法，除非问题给你某种捷径，比如那种复杂度会是多少？是的，我能在足够的时间内完成吗？还是我需要寻找那个捷径，你知道，找出它是什么？这就是解决问题的诀窍吗？这些方法通常会有解决方案供你参考。所以你可以看到你本应该怎么做。然后你可以从中学习。是的，另外，推荐一些关于这方面的阅读材料是
Algorithms in C++ by Robert Sedgwick. And maybe we'll post a link on the blog or something like that. But yeah, Algorithms in C++, it's actually two books. There's a volume one through four, which got assembled into one book, and a volume five, which takes up an entire separate book because it's so epic. But yeah, Robert Sedgwick wrote this Algorithms in C++ series and has amazing theoretical theoretical and application based like framework in it. So he actually talks about like max flow. So in other words
Robert Sedgwick的《算法（C++版）》。也许我们会把链接贴在博客上之类的。但是是的，《算法（C++版）》，它实际上是两本书。第一卷到第四卷被汇编成了一本书，第五卷则单独成册，因为它太宏大了。但是是的，Robert Sedgwick编写了这个《算法（C++版）》系列，其中有令人惊叹的理论和基于应用的框架。所以他实际上谈到了最大流（max flow）。换句话说
given a graph and assume the graph are like pipes and and so they show how much water can go through these pipes. Like how much what's the maximum flow between two nodes? Like assuming that you could use all the pipes right? So he actually talks about the mathematical complexity and then mathematical intuition behind how the algorithm works. And then he shows the algorithm. So highly recommended reading. Yeah.
给定一个图，假设图就像管道，然后他们展示了有多少水可以通过这些管道。比如两个节点之间的最大流量是多少？假设你可以使用所有的管道，对吧？所以他实际上谈到了数学复杂度以及算法工作原理背后的数学直觉。然后他展示了算法。所以强烈推荐阅读。是的。
I mean, it all depends on what kind of programming you end up doing and how much of this you need to know or don't need to know. But yeah, I mean, there are people who major in math, right? Totally. A lot. So yeah, and computer science is closely related to math in many, many ways.
我的意思是，这一切都取决于你最终从事什么样的编程工作，以及你需要或不需要知道多少这些知识。但是是的，我的意思是，确实有人主修数学，对吧？完全正确。很多人。所以是的，计算机科学在许多方面与数学密切相关。
Yeah, it can't hurt to learn that stuff, at least at some level. Yeah. So all right, well, I think that's a wrap. Thank you, everybody who was on at one time or another or is still on the Hangout. Jason's giving you a wave hi. And we appreciate it and we are uh going to
是的，学习这些东西至少在某种程度上没有坏处。好的，好吧，我想这就是总结了。谢谢所有曾经或现在还在Hangout里的每一个人。Jason在向你挥手致意。我们很感激，我们将
be back to our regular episodes we'll have a language for our next time and maybe we'll do another one of these mailbags we'll see give us some feedback let us know what you think did we ramble too long were we too off topic we're always pretty rambly so yeah so it feels good but you should be used to that thank you for all your feedback thank you for all the questions yeah definitely it's uh it's been awesome doing the be used to that. Thank you for all your feedback. Thank you for all the questions. Yeah, definitely. It's been awesome doing the mailbag, answering people's questions. You know, it's great that we sort of like aggregated
回到我们的常规剧集，下次我们将讨论一种语言，也许我们会再做一次这样的邮件袋（mailbag）环节，我们拭目以待。给我们一些反馈，让我们知道你的想法，我们是不是太啰嗦了？我们是不是太偏离主题了？我们总是很啰嗦，所以是的，感觉不错，但你应该习惯这一点。感谢你们所有的反馈，感谢你们所有的问题。是的，绝对的，做邮件袋环节，回答人们的问题真是太棒了。你知道，我们把
a lot of these questions and then we can sort of dedicate a whole episode to it. I think that this worked really well. I appreciate everybody's contributions. And yeah. And thank you all for subscribing. We noticed increased downloadership. Yeah, yeah.
很多这些问题汇总起来，然后我们可以专门用一整集来讨论，这真的很棒。我认为这非常有效。我很感谢大家的贡献。是的。也谢谢大家的订阅。我们注意到下载量增加了。是的，是的。
So a lot of you are either downloading it multiple times or... I can show. Yeah, or... I can share with you guys. Or yeah, we're just becoming more popular. We're not sure what it is. So if you're a new listener,
所以你们很多人要么是多次下载，要么是……我可以展示。是的，或者……我可以和你们分享。或者是的，我们只是变得更受欢迎了。我们不确定是什么原因。所以如果你是一个新听众，
again, like Jason said, well, too late now. You've already listened to this episode. But check out another episode too. Yeah, so we released episode 20, you know, what, maybe three weeks ago or something. And hundreds and hundreds of people
再说一次，就像Jason说的，好吧，现在太晚了。你已经听过这一集了。但也可以看看其他的剧集。是的，所以我们在大概三周前发布了第20集，成百上千的人
have downloaded the episode, which is totally awesome. And we appreciate all of your feedback and questions and comments. So we have a few new languages. Some people said, hey, I don't have a question, but I want you to cover this. And we'll definitely be covering that for the next few weeks. So, yeah, keep your emails coming to programmingthrowdown at gmail.com
下载了这一集，这真是太棒了。我们感谢你们所有的反馈、问题和评论。所以我们有几个新的语言建议。有些人说，嘿，我没有问题，但我希望你们涵盖这个内容。我们肯定会在接下来的几周内涵盖这些内容。所以，是的，请继续发送电子邮件到programmingthrowdown@gmail.com
and keep posting on G+. All right. Thank you, guys. Cool. See you later. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并继续在G+上发帖。好的，谢谢大家。酷。回头见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。